Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 140. Eine weitere Wegmarke wurde genommen. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch hier zu einer neuen Rundreise durch die Geschichten, die keiner hören wollte. Nein, ganz ernsthaft, wir tauchen hier noch mal ein bisschen ein. Wieder keine Technik-Sendung, aber Technik kommt hier trotzdem zur Sprache. Aber ich musste die Gelegenheit einfach mal nutzen. Ich bin auf meiner kleinen Podcast-Tour in Bielefeld vorbeigekommen und schon ganz lange auf meiner Liste steht doch mal, was zu bringen über die, wie soll ich sagen, naja, die wilden 80er, die digitalen 80er, insbesondere die frühen Mailbox-Zeiten und was daraus so geworden ist und wer sollte darüber besser berichten als Padellun und Rena? Hallo Rena. Genau, dein Mikrofon vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher ran. Ich mach dich noch mal ein bisschen lauter hier. Ja, super, dass das geklappt hat. Ich wollte mal mit euch sprechen, weil ihr ja nun auch ganz früh dabei wart. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann hat das so bei euch angefangen mit euren Digital-Begegnungen?
Na, es gibt verschiedene Anfangsdaten. Das eine, das ist etwas identisch mit dem Anfangsdatum von Peter Glaser. Wir haben nämlich am gleichen Composer der Firma IBM schöne Textzeilen rausgelassen und zugehört, wie eine Schreibmaschine Musik macht. Und dann haben sich unsere Wege ein bisschen getrennt. Und der zweite tiefere Einschlag war Rena Tangens Kleinkomputer, ein ZX-80, auf dem wir ein Pornoprogrammiert haben, aber nur in Basic-Sprache, also Pog und Pie, ganz anders betrachtet. Und der dritte größere Einschlag war dann schon 1985, als wir in unserer Galerie Art & Möbel Mont, also hier unter deinen Füßen, eine Veranstaltungsreihe inszeniert haben, die hieß Interregionale Mehrwertvorstellung. Weil wir wollten wissen, wo geht es in der Kunst weiter, weil Bilder malen und blöd durch die Gegend rennen und das eine Performance nennen, war uns ein wenig zu wenig.
Hast du jetzt schon eine Jahreszahl gesagt?
Nee, die wollte ich jetzt ein bisschen noch rauszögern, weil jetzt kommt es erst so richtig. Ich baue da so einen kleinen Spannungsbogen auf. Ja, sehe schon, haben schon einige abgeschaltet. Ist ja okay, dann redet sich gleich viel gemütlicher, dann kann man ein paar heftigere Details noch verkünden. In dieser Veranstaltung, also Galerie, haben wir 1984 das ganz tolle Datum gegründet. 1984 wurde Galerie Art en Meblement gegründet und 85 haben wir nachgeguckt, was machen wir eigentlich, warum machen wir eigentlich eine Galerie, was soll das eigentlich mit dieser komischen Kunst und was ist eigentlich wirklich Kunst. Und dann haben wir diese wunderbare interregionale Mehrwertvorstellung inszeniert, in der wir sechs Menschen und Projekte eingeladen haben, die sich selber nicht als Künstlerinnen oder Künstler betrachtet haben. Da war ein Gärtner dabei, eine Hausfrau, ein Mensch vom Institut für Getriebetechnik aus Hannover, der normalerweise so Keksmaschinen für Balsen baut und es war ein Einbrecher. Der war klasse, das ist eine Geschichte für sich mal, für einen anderen Podcast. Und dann haben wir den Chaos Computer Club eingeladen. Also Bau angerufen, gesagt, komm mal vorbei, bring ein paar Jungs mit und dann machen wir hier drei Tage was hübsches.
Jetzt bist du ja schon voll im Wir. Bleiben wir noch mal ganz kurz bei dir. Ich meine, du wirst ja dann auch irgendwann mal, wann bist du denn das erste Mal auf das Thema Computer, digital, Netze, neue Welten?
Ich glaube, das erste Mal, dass ich einen Computer gesehen habe, war im Holographie-Museum in Puhlheim. Das war irgendwie so ein Ding, ein Monitor mit zwei geraden Strichen und einem Punkt. Die zwei geraden Striche waren Cowboys, der Punkt, ein Pferd, das musste man einfangen. Der zweite Computer, wo ich selber schon ran durfte, der stand, ich kann gar nicht mehr die Jahreszahl sagen, weiß nicht, war so ein rundes Teil, könnte so ein uralt Commodore gewesen sein, im Studio von Konrad Becker in Wien, von der Musikgruppe Monoton, der da auch einiges in den Bereichen dann noch weitergemacht hat. Das war das erste Mal, wo ich dann eine Nacht dran saß und dann immerhin geschafft habe, einen dieser zwei Striche auf dem Monitor ein Stückchen von links nach rechts zu rücken. Das war schon sehr erhebend. Aber die eigentliche Inition fand dann erst so richtig 1985 statt. Abgesehen davon, dass ich immer toll fand, Adressen mit Computern zu verwalten. Ich wollte die Dinge ja zum Arbeiten benutzen.
Also du warst auf jeden Fall nicht schon immer in Bielefeld.
Nee, ich bin ja gar nicht von diesem Planeten. Ich komme ja vom Sinus. Der ist genau eine Unendlichkeit weit entfernt, egal in welche Richtung man geht. Und deswegen heiße ich auch Padellun. Das ist das Geheimnis mit dem Namen. Wir haben da alle so komische Namen. Also für euch Erdenmännchen klingen die immer so komisch. Aber ich komme eigentlich vom Sinus. Also auf und ab.
Das dachte ich mir schon immer. Dann bist du wahrscheinlich vom CoSinus, Rena, oder?
Das ist Rena Tangens.
Dann bist du vom Tangens. Und wie war das bei dir mit der digitalen Konfrontation?
Die wirklichen Erfahrungen machst du dann, wenn du das Teil in der Hand hast und wenn du selber was mitmachen kannst. Und das ist das Wichtige. Und deswegen ging das tatsächlich einmal los mit dem ZX81, halt selber an dem Teil, was mir mein Bruder, seit der abgelegte Rechnerin meines Bruders, der Mathematik studiert hat, daran Sachen ausprobieren zu können. Dann ist es eben meiner. Dann ist es auch egal, wer da hinüber ist. Einfach austesten, was geht. Und das Zweite war, bei Peter Glaser mitzukriegen. Mit dem AC64 kann man über Telefon kommunizieren tatsächlich. Auch das geht. Und dann tatsächlich selber einen Mailbox-Rechner zu betreiben. Das war die wirkliche Erfahrung zu sehen, was passiert eigentlich mit Vernetzung. Da tut sich eine neue Welt auf. Und das war auch bei der Veranstaltung, die wir hier in der Galerie hatten mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Das war eine entscheidende Erkenntnis zu sehen, über Netze in andere Rechner zu gehen, zu schauen, was da läuft. Daraus folgte die Entscheidung zu sagen, das ist nicht nur eine neue Welt, die wir entdecken wollen, sondern das ist auch eine, die wir mitgestalten wollen. Und das ist etwas, was mit unserem Kunstbegriff, nämlich Arda Möbemon, also Kunst als Inneneinrichtung, sehr gut einhergeht. Denn da geht es auch um die Möblerung, um die Einrichtung eines Raumes. Und dieser Raum ist halt sehr, sehr groß geworden. Und an dieser Gestaltung wollen wir mitarbeiten. Und deswegen geht es uns nicht unbedingt darum, tolle, interessante Inhalte, einzelne Inhalte ins Netz zu stellen, sondern uns ging es darum, die Kanäle zu gestalten und sie so zu machen, dass sie möglichst viele Leute ansprechen und sie sich willkommen heißen, selber etwas mitzugestalten und auch so etwas wie eine demokratische Entscheidungsfindung darüber zu befördern, möglich zu machen. Das heißt, dass nicht nur die Leute, die zufällig Geld haben für einen Torenrechner, um einen Server bereit zu stellen, dann die Macht über andere Menschen haben, deren Daten sie transportieren, sondern dass man sich einigt, dass über Dinge diskutiert wird und so etwas wie demokratische Grundwerte eben auch in die Netze mit einzieht. Das war uns wichtig.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt 84 überhaupt erst so auf diese Frühzeit gestoßen seid und so die ersten Zeichen über den Bildschirm flimmerten, wie habt ihr denn dann gleich, also du hast ja jetzt schon mehrere Sachen, du hast jetzt irgendwie Demokratie, Macht, Kontrolle über die Kommunikationswege, da steckt jetzt irgendwie alles schon so ein bisschen drin.
Deine Sendung ist auch einfach nicht lang genug.
Naja, aber wie kam es denn sozusagen, also ich meine, was hat es denn so selbstverständlich gemacht, jetzt diesen Bogen gleich so zu spannen? Ich meine, andere Leute haben dann erst mal zwei Jahre mit Chatten verbracht und hatten einfach Spaß. Was war denn da jetzt sozusagen die Erkenntnis in dieser Begegnung, dass solche Themen eine Rolle spielen würden?
Naja, wir haben aus der Erkenntnis halt gleich Taten folgen lassen und haben eine Veranstaltung kreiert, nämlich die Public Domain, also öffentlicher Bereich oder auch öffentliche Angelegenheit. Und diese Veranstaltungsreihe Public Domain war immer am ersten Sonntag im Bunker Ulmenwall hier in Bielefeld. Und sie ist es auch immer noch? Und das war ursprünglich eine Veranstaltung für alle Leute, die sich irgendwie für Computer interessieren und eine Idee haben. Damit könnte man mehr machen als Textverarbeitung, spielen, chatten und so. Und zunächst mal gab es kein bestimmtes Programm, sondern es war einfach ein Treffen. Und aus diesem Treffen, aus dieser Gruppe von Leuten, die da kamen, und da standen gleich beim ersten Treffen 100 Leute vor der Tür. Das war irre.
Wie habt ihr denn das vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen? Also ihr seid, habt euch irgendwie, seid euch in Bielefeld begegnet, nehme ich an. Und dann irgendwie...
Wir sind uns in Berlin begegnet.
Gut, wie auch immer. Ihr seid euch irgendwo begegnet. Auf jeden Fall habt ihr beschlossen, gemeinsam Dinge zu tun.
Seit 1984 mache ein paar Lund. Ich gemeinsam in Bielefeld hier das Kunstprojekt Ardameblement.
Genau. Das war sozusagen der erste Name, den ihr euch gegeben habt.
Genau. Den haben wir auch nach wie vor. Das Kunstprojekt gibt es auch nach wie vor.
Und dieses Kunstprojekt hat dann auch die Public Domain ins Leben gerufen?
Genau. Ardameblement hat die Veranstaltung mit dem Chaos Computer Club gehabt. Da haben sich zum ersten Mal Leute getroffen, die sich für das Thema interessieren.
Und zwar, da muss ich dazu sagen, das war nämlich klasse. Also wir haben ja viele Veranstaltungen gemacht und das war die Veranstaltung. Da kamen Leute hin, A, sehr jung, B, wussten die, wo es lang geht, C, hatten die ein tolles Funkeln in den Augen. Also eins, was an anderen Stellen einfach gefehlt hat. Und die waren alle so freundlich und es hat Spaß gemacht. Und das war, glaube ich, auch mit einer der Gründe, weil wir sagten, jawohl, da wollen wir mitmachen. Das geht in die richtige Richtung. Wir wollen ja, das muss ich jetzt gestehen, die Welt ja ein bisschen verbessern. Und deswegen haben wir lieber mit freundlichen Leuten zusammengearbeitet.
Was hat denn da gefunkelt?
Wissen. Wissensdurst, Begierde, Lust, was zu schaffen. Weg von diesem Verweigerungshaltung, sondern richtig mal was in die Hand nehmen, Dinge erforschen und anderen Wissen mitzuteilen, also das auch zu teilen. Das Tolle war ja, bei diesen Dreckscomputern, da wurde ja irgendwelche Hardware angeliefert, aber Software und Handbücher fehlten. Also musste man sich mit anderen unterhalten und selbst mit Leuten sprechen, wo man normalerweise die Straßenseite gewechselt hätte, wenn man ihnen begegnet wäre. Und dann konnte man feststellen, aufgrund des Zwangs, dass man sich auch austauschen wollte, mitzukriegen. Und die sind gar nicht so schlimm, mit denen kann man ganz gut was zusammen machen.
Was für eine Verweigerung fällt um ein so?
Also diese ganze Pankige Coolness, die man sich dann schon als cooler Mensch angewöhnt hatte, als man noch nicht wusste, dass cool sein völlig uncool ist. Und das war dann nicht mehr so.
Ja, natürlich auch Computern gegenüber, denn das waren ja vorher die Computer der Anderen, die großen Bösen und das änderte sich ja nun gerade. Und dort kamen die Leute hin, die sich ansonsten im Kaufhaus getroffen haben, um dort Programme zu kopieren. Und die hatten dort jetzt erst das erste Mal einen Freiraum, um sich zu treffen und auszutauschen und sich auch gegenseitig Aufgaben zu stellen oder die anderen zu fragen, was machst du denn gerade?
In den ersten Datenschleudern muss man mal erwähnen, da stand noch drin, wie viel Salz man in den Kaffee rühren muss, damit er versehentlich über die Tastatur geschüttet den Computer zum Erliegen bringt. Also das war noch eine ganz andere Szene. Also die Macht wieder zu gewinnen über diese Geräte, über die man sich so ohnmächtig gegenüberfühlt in diesem Großrechner, das war einer der ganz wichtigen Punkte.
Aber wurden denn diese Großrechner überhaupt wahrgenommen?
Als Bedrohung ja. Als Big Brother, als Steve.
Hey, die waren doch total gegenwärtig. Wegen Volkszählung. Also, das war klar. Der große Rechner war halt der vom Feind, und der Staat war gefährlich.
Okay, aber Volkszählung ist jetzt das Thema 87 gewesen.
84.
Nein, nein, das war ja viel früher. 83 ist das Volkszählungsurteil schon gesprochen worden.
84 hatte die Buchmesse Orwell als Thema.
Der Widerstand war lange vorher.
Ach so, okay, 87 fand sie dann statt.
Das Bewusstsein, das allgemeine Bewusstsein deswegen zu Computern war halt eins, gefährlich, Datenverarbeitung.
Rasterfahndung, Horst Herold. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass überall in den Straßen mit Maschinengewehren bewaffnete Polizisten standen, wo man wusste, die murksen einen ab, wenn man nur die Oberlippe hochzieht.
Wir reden ja jetzt von der Zeit, die sozusagen die unmittelbare Nachwirkung der RAF-Terrorzeit war, sozusagen der erste Terrorwahn, den Deutschland so aktiv ausgelebt hat nach dem Krieg.
Und immer noch nicht bewältigt hat. Die sagen heute noch Ausstellungen ab dafür.
Es ist definitiv auch immer noch so ein Thema. Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen mal, es ist schwierig, so etwas zu skizzieren, aber ich finde es immer interessant, dass man sich überhaupt erst mal vorstellen kann, was eigentlich damals die Köpfe beschäftigt hat. Ich meine, es ist ja eh schon absurd, dass diese ganze Computerszenerie, so Chaos Computer Club und eben diese ganzen Sphären, sich alle irgendwie ausgerechnet 1984 geformt haben. Der erste Kongress, die erste Datenschleuder usw. Ich hatte es ja auch im Gespräch mit Peter Glaser hier schon auch schon mal so ähnlich rausgearbeitet. Das war ja keine Absicht. Das war ja eigentlich eher Zufall, dass die technologische Entwicklung dann auch... .da war, dass dann die Leute eben auch die Geräte selber in die Hand genommen haben.
Ein offenes Fenster, Window of Change.
Genau, und du sagst ja irgendwie, Punk war auf einmal dann doch nicht mehr cool. Du hast da ja auch selber so ein bisschen mitgerockt. Was war denn da für ein Wertewandel am Start? Also was hat man denn auf einmal anders gesehen?
Also für mich war das schon... Ich bin einfach in eine andere Szene eingetaucht. Zuteil gleiche Leute wieder kennengelernt. Also einer der ersten Leute, der mit dem Apple in Hamburg in der Wohnung von Peter auftauchte, war halt auch ein Punk. Aber Punk war ja, ich sag jetzt mal auch, eher ein Betriebssystem. Und dann, was sich dann computermäßig dann erst mal entwickelt hat, war dann halt eine weitere Anwendung da drauf. Also nicht ohne Grund. Gab's eine Zeit lang den Begriff Cipherpunk oder Cyberpunk. Das hat ja auch schon eine gewisse Nähe. Und ich glaube, der Punk war auch ganz wichtig, um den Respekt zu verlieren. Nicht nur vor dem, was die Gesellschaft einem auftruiert, sondern eben auch vor Geräten. Und das wurde dann genutzt. Da hat sich Punk dann in einer anderen Form gezeigt. Nur irgendwann waren da nicht mehr die Bullen die Bösen. Und schon sind sie, dass ich dieses böse Wort verwendet habe. Man sagt ja heute cops. Sondern plötzlich waren es dann die Postler, weil die einem irgendwie die Wohnung durchsuchten, wenn man einen Modem angeschlossen hat, illegal. Also da hat sich nicht so viel gewandelt. Aber in dem Sinne eines Paradigmenwechsels, also der ja was ganz, ganz Kleines ist, hat das gewaltige Auswirkungen gehabt.
Das heißt, der Großrechner war sozusagen das Symbol für den Staat?
Die Allmacht. Die Allmacht in der Hand von ganz wenigen. Horst Herold.
Und das Großartige war jetzt halt selber, kleine Maschinen in der Hand zu haben, mit denen was tun zu können. Und letzten Endes ist das auch Punk, nämlich einfach selber was machen, ausprobieren, tun. Keine Ehrfeucht vor, wieder Musikgeräten, was auch immer zu haben, sondern es tun. Und das haben dort Leute gemacht. Und in dieser kreativen Szene, also Ende 85 war die Veranstaltung mit Kraus Computer Club hier bei uns in der Galerie. Über 86 haben wir versucht, diese Veranstaltung klarzumachen, also Räume dafür zu finden. Und Januar 87 hat es dann funktioniert. Und seitdem sind wir im Burkaum im Wall. Und seitdem gibt es diese Veranstaltung dort. Und das war dann sozusagen auch diese kreative Brutstätte für ganz viele Geschichten. Wir haben verschiedene Themen dann aufgegriffen, die Leute einfach interessiert haben. Das konnte dann einfach eine richtig geile Copyparty sein, die ganz konspirativ lief.
Das war dann unsere erste Hausdurchsuchung.
Oder die Idee, was wollen wir machen? Wir wollen ein eigenes Kommunikationssystem aufbauen. Insofern ist die Mailbox, die wir hier in Bielefeld aufgebaut haben, nicht die Kopfgeburt von einem Einzelnen, sondern ein gemeinsames Projekt gewesen, wo wir gesagt haben, wir wollen unser eigenes Kommunikationssystem. Da soll uns niemand reinreden, da soll es keine Zensur geben.
Alle sollen Systembetreiber sein.
Wir wollen die Themen bestimmen und so weiter.
Die Public Domain, ich war irgendwann mal da. Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, wann. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich erinnere mich an eine Geschichte mit einer Party und der Freundin von jemand anderem.
Also wir reden ja jetzt hier nicht über mich, sondern über euch. Also die Public Domain, wie war denn das? Die erste war doch dann gleich irgendwie ein Verruf und die Polizei wollte...
Nein, nein, nein. Die Public Domains waren alle cool und alle prima. Bloß eine Idee, die daraus entstand, war, warum machen wir nicht mal eine richtig geile Copyparty, also wo die ganzen verbotenen Sachen auch laufen, wo Sachen gekriegt werden und und und.
Verstehe, das war sozusagen separat. Die Bitnapping-Party.
Genau, das war dann die Bitnapping-Party und zu der laden wir separat ein und zwar die ganzen Tauschpartner. Damals hat man das ganz konspirativ über eine Postlagerkarte gemacht. Also die Kids haben über Postlagerkarten Software getauscht. Also da wurden nämlich noch das Ketten zugeschickt.
Wie funktioniert eine Post?
Das ist wie ein Postfach, bloß dass du dich dafür nicht identifizieren musstest. Also du hast dann einfach eine Abholkarte. Das war damals eine Art anonymer Briefkasten, den die Post unterhalten hat.
Das heißt, man konnte einfach irgendein Item in irgendeiner Verpackung bringen, dann lagerte das dort?
Nein, nein, du schickst es dahin. Du schickst es an die Postlagerkarte, Nummer so und so, in Bielefeld oder weiß da gar ja wo. Und derjenige, der die Karte hat, um das abholen zu können, kann das dann dort einsammeln. Und das ist eine komplett anonyme Möglichkeit gewesen, Leuten Post zu schicken. Die müssen ihre Adresse nicht preisgeben und so. Und das haben die Kids damals halt intensiv genutzt. Und das war ganz wunderbar. Wir haben dann Einladungen halt richtig schön professionell gedruckt, auch noch kaschiert und darunter einen UV-Stempel gehabt. Und mit einem Paginierstempel durchgestempelt. Das heißt, jede Karte hat eine Nummer. Und die haben wir an die einzelnen Adressen verschickt, die unsere Kids, die selber Software gekrägt haben und Demos geschrieben haben und so weiter, die haben die Adressen rausgesucht, an welche Postlagerkarte jetzt Einladung geschickt wird. Und die Veranstaltung war unglaublich voll. Es war rappelvoll. Es waren Massen von Leuten da.
Das war auch ein Bunkeröhenwall.
Zufällig, aber es war...
Also wir haben da schon eine Zusammenarbeit mit dem Jugendamt gemacht.
Das wusste das Jugendamt aber nicht. Wir haben die Räume halt gemietet dafür.
Das klingt natürlich jetzt irgendwie hochgradig verboten, aber auch wenn ich jetzt selber nochmal in die Zeit zurückdenke, damals war ja eigentlich das Crecken von Software, das war ja geradezu eine Ehrentat, weil es ja einfach keine gab. Also dieses ganze, wo man sich alles runterladen konnte oder überhaupt die Verfügbarkeit von Software fand ja de facto nicht statt. Das heißt, dieses private Kopieren bzw. dann eben auch so das Möglichmachen des Kopierens, das war eigentlich echte Community-Tätigkeit, oder?
Vor allen Dingen, die Software war ja auch meist völliger Dreck, also die wollte ja auch gar keiner haben, also bis auf zwei, drei Sachen oder so. Und das Spannende war halt, diesen Kopierschutz zu crecken oder einen Debugger zu schreiben, mit dem man das gecrekt kriegt. Und die Leute, die es damals gemacht haben, das sind heute Professoren, oder fliegen durch die Welt und machen den Support für immer dann, wenn es brennt in irgendeiner Firma. Also da hat man richtig was dran gelernt. Das war einfach geistig anregend. Die Software, der größte Teil war wirklich völliger Dreck und Blödsinn und kommerzieller Scheiß, den höchstens die Tante, weil sie keine Ahnung hatte, dem Enkel zum Geburtstag geschenkt hat. Der dann geweint hat, weil er hatte sie schon, ungekreckt.
So, das heißt, ihr habt einerseits relativ schnell durch diese Veranstaltung mit dem Club und dann durch die Public Domain, die monatlich stattfandet, sozusagen Kontakt aufgenommen mit so einer neuen, frischen Szene, die irgendwie, wie du sagtest, das Funken in den Augen hatte. Und das war dann irgendwie das. Zu welchem Zeitpunkt kam denn dieser Mailbox-Aspekt dann da rein?
Ich erinnere mich an eine Autofahrt zurück vom Kongress. Das muss 98, 98, ne, 97, 80, 80.
Das war 88. Rückfahrt vom Kongress, 88.
Da saßen wir mit Papi im Auto und da kam so die Idee auf, lass uns einfach zusammenlegen und wir kaufen zusammen einen Rechner. Und dann werden wir alle Sys-Up und befreien uns von diesen blöden, blöden, weiß nicht, Bastards, die irgendwo Mailboxen gratis hinstellen und dafür geliebt werden wollen, bevor sie ein höheres Priolevel geben. Und dann haben wir halt unsere Mailbox, der Systembetreiberin. Irgendwann hat mir mal Marco durch den Bunker zugerufen, Paulun, Wilson, Modem, 50 Mark. 50 Mark dachte ich nämlich auf jeden Fall. Er hatte 350 gesagt insofern.
Aber wir hatten es dann und dann.
Und dann sind wir halt auch durch die Gegend und waren halt ein bisschen vorsichtig, haben uns auch in Datex P eingewählt, aber tatsächlich legal. Also wir haben das dann auch bezahlt.
Wir haben unendliche Mengen an Geld an die Telekom abgelatzt. Zumal wir noch drei Monate in Kanada waren und auch dort über das Pendant von Datex P tätig waren.
Und die Taz-Nuis haben wir nur ganz selten verwendet, die von Big Schreibmaschinen. Also wirklich nur ganz selten, weil wir fanden das unfair. Wir haben die nicht selber gekriegt, sondern von anderen bekommen. Und na gut, mit dem Taz-Computer, das hatten wir selber rausgefunden.
Ja, der Nui- und Nuasport, den hatte ich ja auch schon mal ausführlich mit Hans-Hans-Hügner besprochen. Ausgabe 100. Da haben wir das mal im Detail beleuchtet, wen das interessiert. Marc darf vielleicht noch mal reinhören. Aber ihr wolltet dann sozusagen eure eigene Mailbox aufziehen.
Ja, und dann begab sich der günstige Fall, dass wir einen Rechner gespendet bekamen. Und wir nahmen ihn dann auseinander. Es war just bei einer Public Domain, wo wir den bekamen. Und jemand, der sich damit rauskannte, schaute ihn sich an und sagte, wow, das ist kein XD, das ist ein AT. Also ein 286er.
Ja, die war schnell. Eine 20er-Platte war da drin. 20 Megabyte. Kann sein, ja.
Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls 20 Megabyte Festplatte. Ja, und wir haben die dann sofort verwendet, um dann einen unserer User anzuchatten. Von dem hatte nämlich jemand anders gerade noch eine 20er Festplatte ausgeliehen. Und haben ihn dann gefragt, ob er uns die zur Verfügung stellen würde. Und haben sie ihm dann abgeschwatzt.
Genau, während sie aber schon eingebaut war.
Während sie schon in unseren Rechner eingebaut war. Damit hatten wir dann 40 Megabyte.
Die brauchst du doch sicherlich nicht mehr, oder?
Ja, also es haben sich viele beteiligt und haben auch gespendet und so. Die Mailbox war also von Anfang an immer ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt. Und da wir alle keine reichen Eltern haben, haben wir für den Betrieb, also damals waren Telefongebühren außerhalb der Ortstarife eben auch teuer. Und um das alles zu finanzieren, haben wir auch Gebühren genommen von den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern.
Ja, vielleicht für die Leute, die das jetzt hören und eher in dem Jahr geboren wurden, als dass sie dort Mailboxen installiert haben, noch mal klarzumachen. Mit Mailbox meinen wir ein Computer, an dem eine oder mehrere Modems angeschlossen waren. Dahinter dann die entsprechende Anzahl von Telefonleitungen, analog, ratarata. Sodass mehrere Leute, oder mindestens einer, aber im Idealfall mehrere Leute, dann gleichzeitig diesen Rechner angerufen haben, die sich mit der Mailbox-Software verbunden haben. Einfach so auf Terminal-Ebene. Und dann kam halt so ein einfaches Textinterface mit irgendwie Menü hier, Menü da. Verschiedene Systeme waren damals en vogue. Es gab das Fido-Netz.
Fido, das war eigentlich das große, bekannte, berühmte, sehr zentralistisch aufgebaut. Wir wollten ein dezentrales Netzwerkssystem. Das wurde am Rande des Chaos Computer Clubs programmiert. Es gab da verschiedene Projekte. Das Projekt, was sich dann zu uns rüber geforkt hatte, war dann das Projekt Cerberus.
Da sagt der Name halt schon.
Vor allen Dingen war das ein System, das uns deswegen gut gefiel, weil es war ein fast sklavischer, also von der Oberfläche her sklavischer Nachbau des Geonet-Mail-Systems von Günther Leuhe, dem in meinen Augen Mailbox Großpapst der Welt, der das Geonet aufgezogen hat. Und wir haben damit auf Reisen international immer viel gearbeitet mit Geonet und konnten da halt mit Leuten chatten und haben das immer verwendet, um neue Kommunikationsmedien zu zeigen. Und Cerberus war am Anfang für uns so ein bisschen wie so eine billige Geonet-Mailbox. Und erst als wir selber eine hatten, stellt man fest, wie toll das ist, dass man nicht so unendlich viel Geld in die Technik stecken muss, was bei Geonet eben auch noch sehr teuer war, sondern dass man einfach eben so ein Rechner hat und die Mailbox-Software und damit selber Herr über das Geschehen da drin. Also nicht das Geschehen, was die Einzelnen machen, sondern dass man das einrichten kann, Leute lenken kann, vorgeben kann. Wir haben dann auch sehr zum Entsetzen von den richtig harten Mailbox-Freaks auch ein Sprachmodul auf sie umgepätscht und auf weiblich. Also dass nicht nur Hallo, du bist der Sohn Sofiel, der Anrufer drin stand, sondern man begrüßt wurde, das ist der Sohn Sofiel, der Anruf. Und damit sich Frauen auch mal mitgemein fühlten. Und das war dann ganz spannend. Für uns war das total toll, weil wir haben auch zum ersten Mal gesehen, wie viel Macht wir als Systemputzfrauen über die Leute haben, die das System benutzen. Das war uns selber zwar immer theoretisch klar. Man kann schon immer sagen, jemand, der Zugriff auf die Technik hat, der weiß ganz viel und der kann das ganz toll missbrauchen. Aber es selber wirklich auszuprobieren, unter den eigenen Händen zu haben und mitzukriegen, ja, ich sehe jetzt, dass Matthias an Claudia schreibt. Ja, ich wusste nicht, dass sich zwischen den beiden was anbahnt. Ja, jetzt weiß ich es.
Das wollte ich aber nicht wissen.
Genau, das geht mich gar nichts an. Dass diese Aspekte wirklich so deutlich da sind, haben wir erst dadurch begriffen, dass wir selber Provider, wie man heute sagt, waren, also damals Mailbox-Betreiber. Und das war auch für uns eine Grundlage, warum wir uns mit den Programmieren dieser Software dann zusammengetan haben. Wir haben dann tatsächlich später sogar eine Firma zusammengemacht, um irgendwie die Arbeit besser verteilen zu können.
Jetzt sprängst du ein bisschen viel. Also wir haben uns dann in die Softwaregestaltung halt eingemischt, weil es ein, also wir haben angefangen damit, dass wir ein Handbuch für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer geschrieben haben. Und weil wir einfach wollten, dass möglichst viele Leute das verwenden können.
Nicht nur geschrieben, sondern gedruckt. Wir haben es drucken lassen. Alle anderen haben immer nur noch ASCII-Texte rausgegeben, weil sie dachten, das reicht.
Ja, also wir haben uns bemüht, ein verständliches Handbuch zu schreiben für die Benutzung. Und dann fielen uns bei einigen Stellen auf, das ist scheiße zu erklären. Das ist einfach auch scheiße in der Handhabung. Also muss das am Programm geändert werden. Haben uns dann an die Programmierer herangemacht und haben erstaunt festgestellt, dass die ganz offen waren und sich über Anregungen gefreut haben. Bei einigen Sachen hat es nicht geklappt, aber bei anderen hat es sehr gut geklappt. Und wir haben ziemlich viel eingebaut. Somit, das erste, was gemacht wurde, war, dass eine Verschlüsselung eingebaut wurde der privaten Postfächer. Das heißt, dass für die Systembetreiber nicht mehr mitlesbar war, was jemand im Postfach liegen hat und auch nicht in dem Moment, wo jemand eine Nachricht gerade eintippt. Extrem wichtig. Wir haben später mit den Programmierern dann noch enger zusammengearbeitet. Wir haben dann im Auftrag auch das Handbuch für die SysOps geschrieben. Das war dann ein Werk von 700 Seiten in LaTeX und mit Beschreibung sämtlicher Konfigurationsdateien, damit Leute da auch selber drum rum basteln können.
SysOps, System Operator, die Betreiber der Mailbox. Damals ein stehender Begriff, heute auch, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr in Benutzung, ja. Auf der Ebene haben wir, glaube ich, durch das Denken von der Nutzerseite her sehr viel für dieses Programm getan, das an den Stellen umgestaltet wurde. Wichtig war uns ansonsten an Cerberus noch, dass es Low-Tech war und Low-Cost. Man konnte es mit Rechnern betreiben, die jetzt nicht super aufgerüstet waren und superschnell und teuer, sondern das Programm war auf sparsame Ressourcennutzung angelegt. Und zwar sowohl für das Programm selber, was auf dem Server lief, wie auch für die einzelnen Leute, die das Programm verwenden. Muss man sich vorstellen, wenn man heutzutage mal so einen Header anschaut, so einen Kopf von einer E-Mail, das ist wahnsinnig lang, was da an Zeilen gibt. Damals waren die Zeilen fest begrenzt auf das Allerwichtigste, einfach weil die Geschwindigkeit zum Teil 300 Bit pro Sekunde war. Und um sozusagen das Portemonnaie der einzelnen Nutzerinnen und Nutzer zu schunen, war das damals halt begrenzt.
Damals wurden noch echte Kriege darüber ausgefochten, wenn jemand mal eine Signature an seiner Mail verwendet hat, die länger als zwei Zeilen war.
Ja, das machte halt Kosten. Und wenn man, das ist auch noch ein wichtiger Punkt, es ging eben nicht nur um private E-Mails, die dieser Server verteilt hat. Beim Mailbox denken ja viele, es ging um private Mails, sondern eben auch um News, also um öffentliche Nachrichten. Und das war für mich auch der besonders spannende Teil, nämlich die Möglichkeit, zum ersten Mal veröffentlichen zu können. Also an Leute zu schreiben, Leute zu erreichen, die ich noch gar nicht kenne, die sich aber für ein bestimmtes Thema interessieren. Und das war der neue Aspekt, den Mailboxen mit sich getragen haben. Das deutsche Wort Mailboxen ist ziemlich unpräzise, das Englische ist Bulletin Boards. Und das sagt es eigentlich besser. Also es ist eher ein schwarzes Brett, wo man was anpinnen kann, damit andere Leute es lesen. Das Feature mit privater E-Mail lief natürlich auch.
Ja, es ist interessant, dass sich da in Deutschland ein ganz anderer Begriff etabliert hat. Also im nahen Ausland kann man mit dem Begriff Mailbox schnell missverstanden werden. Das war nur in Deutschland so. Aber es ist auch nochmal ganz interessant festzuhalten, dass das im Prinzip damals wie auch im Usenet, aus dem ja dann später so ein bisschen die Internetkultur auch erwuchs, in der Mailbox-Szene auch im Wesentlichen private E-Mail und eben die Foren, die öffentlichen Foren, die schwarzen Bretter quasi, die die Hauptrolle gespielt haben. Manche hatten dann auch noch so eine Live-Chat-Option, wenn halt tatsächlich mehrere Modems an dem Rechner dranhingen. Also es gab ja auch welche, die wirklich nur eins hatten. Da konnte dann halt immer nur einer gleichzeitig. Das ist wirklich unfassbar, wenn man da heutzutage zurückschaut. Aber so war es. Und trotzdem war das eine unglaubliche Faszination, weil die Alternative dazu war ja einfach nüscht. Es gab halt Telefon und das war es. Und Fernsehen.
Fernsehen gucken.
Und Radio.
Gerieselt werden und nicht interagieren.
Wer hat denn dann, also eure Mailbox hieß Bionic? Warum?
Haben wir uns ausgedacht.
Na ja, es war ein langer Prozess und den Namen hat Rena irgendwann. Na doch, da steckt BI drin, Bielefeld, also bionische Technik.
Wir haben es als Lebewesen eben auch gesehen mit Eigenleben. Also etwas, was wir nicht komplett bestimmen können.
Dann ON, BION. ON war unsere Zeitung, die wir damals gemacht haben. Das steckte mit drin und IC, wie Integrated Circuit, also Bielefeld auf Chip. Also da kann man ganz viel mit spielen und das war ein sehr geniales Wort. Ich hoffe, sowas würde uns mal statt unseres Vereinsnamens einfallen.
Ihr hattet auch immer schon diesen Doppelslash irgendwie am Start, oder?
Der ist durch die Mailbox so gekommen. Dieser Doppelslash ist ein doppelter Devotionalstrich. Der Devotionalstrich ist eigentlich der eine Strich, den man macht, wenn man an den König schreibt. Man macht einen Strich und dann erst unterschreibt man, um seine Hochachtung gegenüber und seinen niedrigen Stand gegenüber dem König auszudrücken. Das heißt, jeden, dem ich schreibe und stelle dann diese zwei Striche hervor, das zeige ich, dass ich ihn sehr achte, auch wenn ich gratutierisch beschimpft habe.
Und wem wird da geholtigt jetzt mit dem Doppelstrich?
Jedem, dem ich oder jeder, der ich schreibe.
Ich meine, ihr habt ja da so ein bisschen dem Web vorweg gegriffen. Tim Berners-Lee hat vor ein paar Tagen in einem Interview gesagt, auf die Frage, was er denn diesmal anders machen würde, diesmal würde er irgendwie diesen Doppelstrich weglassen.
Ja, er hat es ihm damals toll gefunden. Ich glaube, er war auch Member unserer Mailbox und ist daher da drauf gekommen. Lügen darf man auch, oder?
Auf den alten Disketten nochmal nach der Userliste gucken.
Also es waren hier ganz viele tolle Leute in dieser Mailbox. Das ist ganz unglaublich.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Wir hatten Entwicklungshelfer, die in Indonesien irgendwo sonst wo waren, und die über Mailbox und dann mit ihrer Frau noch den Kontakt gehalten haben, weil das ansonsten schwierig war.
Ganz viele Journalisten hatten neben ihrem Sowell-Account wurde es dann schick, auch ein Bionic-Account zu haben. Und dann haben sich dann hier die Top-Journalisten aus der IT-Branche, es gab ja nicht so viele, hier auch in der Bionic niederlassen, weil die war auch zuverlässig. Es hat halt auch einfach als Service gut funktioniert, sehr niederschwellig und Sowell war ein populäres Mailbox-System in Kalifornien. Genau. Wenn man da den Gründer interviewen musste, musste man ein Flugticket kaufen, dem viel Geld bezahlen, dann fuhr man wieder hier zurück und hat den hoch in den Himmel gelobt, weil es zu teuer war. Uns hat man immer gratis interviewt und dann wurden die Artikel zusammengestrichen. Also fragst du mal Profet werden willst, lieber Tim.
Ich?
Zieh um, in die USA. Einmal Fingerabdrücke abgeben und dann Geld für Interviews nehmen. Genau. Liebe Chaosradio Express Leute, wir hätten auch, also Rena und ich hätten auch gerne Bahncard 100, wenn ich das mal hier sagen darf. Spendenkonto Nummer 2129799 bei der Sparkasse in Bielefeld 480 50161. Vielen Dank. Das war der Werbeblock. Habt ihr euch die Nummer aufgeschrieben? Also nochmal 2129799.
So, also Mailbox-Site, Kunstgemacht, Public Domain geprägt. Den Begriff, da wollte ich nochmal nachfragen, der war ja damals auch ein spezieller Begriff. Public Domain ist mittlerweile irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig da.
Das gab es damals aber auch noch nicht. Wir haben, das war so eine von vielen Ideen, die irgendwie rumging, aber Public Domain-Software, wie es dann später so groß wurde, gab es noch nicht. Sondern das war tatsächlich, man wurde damit überlaufen. Also wir haben den schon so mitbekommen. Es gibt sowas wie Public Domain-Software.
Das war auch nicht die Bedeutung für die Veranstaltungsreihe, sondern wie gesagt öffentlicher Bereich. Aber auch in dem Sinne, hier darf jeder hinkommen und jede natürlich. Aber auch in dem Sinne öffentliche Angelegenheit. Das ist etwas, worum wir uns kümmern sollten. Und in dem Sinne haben wir auch immer Leute eingeladen, die Themen gerade bearbeiten, die uns selber interessiert haben. Also das war immer eine Möglichkeit, wo Leute aus dem Kreis heraus, die etwas Besonderes gemacht haben, also ein Forum hatten, wo sie etwas vorstellen konnten. Aber wir haben auch Leute von auswärts eingeladen, die uns etwas Interessantes mitzuteilen haben. Und daraus haben sich auch sehr viele weitere Beziehungen ergeben. Und das funktioniert bei der Public Domain immer noch. Public Domain hat dann eine ganze, also das ist ja aus diesem Treffen von Computerfreaks entstanden und wo die Leute auch alle mit Rechner gekommen sind. Man muss sich das vorstellen, wir mussten dann jedes Mal Tische dort anschleppen, weil das normalerweise der Bunker immer mal ein Jazzkeller ist. Und da braucht man keine Tische, sondern da hat man bestenfalls Stühle und hockt da halt um die Bühne rum. Und wir haben jedes Mal Tische angeschleppt und es waren dann 50 Leute mit Rechner alleine da. Und insgesamt 100. Das war irre. Also wo viele Leute eben selber was gemacht haben. Und wir haben dann angefangen, als wir das Gefühl hatten, es wird mehr zu einer reinen Kopierveranstaltung, dann haben wir angefangen, jeder Veranstaltung ein Thema zu geben und hatten dann Leute, die was erzählt haben oder was vorgeführt haben und so. Und dann teilte sich die Veranstaltung so ein bisschen. Dann gab es halt anfangs Vortrag. Und dann saßen aber immer noch Leute da in den Reihen mit Rechnern. Und die warteten dann drauf, dass dann wieder Ruhe ist mit dem Vortrag und sie halt weitermachen können. Und wir hatten sehr schöne Szenen da, wo zum Beispiel Günther von Grafenreuth etwas über verschiedene rechtliche Begriffe erzählt hat. Und wo er dann am Ende sagt, so Leute, ich fahre dann auch gleich, damit ihr dann wieder Fast Copy spielen könnt. Und irgendwann sind die Leute mit Rechnern nicht mehr gekommen. Einfach auch, weil das gar nicht mehr nötig war. Denn Software gab es mittlerweile sonst wo. Und auch Foren, also es hat sich weiter ausdifferenziert. Programmierer konnten sich an anderen Stellen treffen und so. Dafür war das Bedürfnis nicht mehr da, sondern jetzt gibt es da halt eben... Und war das?... ausschließlich geistige Nahrung. Schwer zu sagen.
Auch mit den 90er Jahren begann das, oder? Ich glaube, das Internet. Der Beginn des Internets hat da ganz viel...
Ja, aber ich finde...
Ja, das ist schon klar.
Ich versuche nur gerade sozusagen an der Stelle jetzt mal den Beginn des Internets zu markieren.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das war so im Grunde im Ablauf 92.
Nee, die waren noch viel länger da. Also Leute mit Rechnern waren mindestens bis Mitte der 90er dabei, wenn nicht noch später. Also das ist eine ganze Zeit lang noch beharrlich gewesen, dass so ein paar Reihen dann...
Ja, aber die gewisse Stagnation war dann schon. Also auch Trennungen, also auch wo Leute im FoeBoot das Scheiße fanden, dass wir jetzt nicht Provider wurden. Und wir eben einfach schon aus Holland wussten, dass Provider werden als kleinen Firma kein Dauerkonzept ist, sondern dass es nur dann sinnvoll ist, wenn man weiß, an wem man es dann gleich verkaufen wird. Und wir haben das halt nicht gemacht. Und das hat viele Leute dann auch vom FoeBoot weggetrieben. Und dann fing es auch mehr an, dass weniger Technikfreaks in FoeBoot kamen, sondern schon mehr Leute, die an gesellschaftlichen Sachen interessiert waren. Also noch mehr als vorher.
Ja, neuer Begriff in unserem Gespräch. FoeBoot gibt es seit wann?
Seit 1987. Und zwar der FoeBoot hat sich aus den aktiven Besucherinnen und Besuchern der Public Domain gegründet. Und zwar einfach aus der Notwendigkeit raus, zusammen eine gemeinsame Kasse zu haben, um zum Beispiel so etwas wie ein Projektionsgerät, was damals noch nicht Beamer war, sondern...
So ein Ding zum Draufsetzen auf ein Overhead-Projekt, oder?
Um so etwas ausleihen zu können. Oder eben irgendwann später gemeinsam zu kaufen. Und ähnliche Geschichten. Und dafür haben wir dann diesen komischen Verein gegründet. Die Satzung haben wir uns per DFÜ, ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Begriff schon mal aufgetaucht ist, Datenfernübertragung, haben wir uns also rübergeholt, per Modem die Satzung vom Chaos Computer Club. Und haben die dann leider, furchtbares Munstrum, dann auf unseren Rechner überspielt und haben dann mit Suchen und Ersetzen Chaos Computer Club durch FoeBuD ersetzt. Dieser Name ist von Reinhard Schruzki damals erfunden worden. Und zwar auf dem Weg die Treppe runter in den Bunker Ullmenwall. Reinhard hatte damals bei der Post gearbeitet. Damals, als die Post noch für die Telekommunikation zuständig war. Und da gab es diese furchtbaren Abstrusenabkürzungen für ganz einfache Dinge. Also Abkürzungen, die alles viel komplizierter machen. Zum Beispiel Fetapp mit Gebarns. Fernsprech-Tischapparat mit Gebührenanzeiger. Fetapp mit Gebarns ist das, was normale Menschen Telefon nennen. Und da gab es bei der Post auch sowas wie den bewegten und unbewegten Landfunk. Und Reinhard fiel dann dieses Monstrum ein. Verein zur Förderung des öffentlichen, bewegten und unbewegten Datenverkehrs. Und damals waren wir noch naiv genug zu denken, ist doch total egal, wie dieser blöde Verein heißt. Wichtig ist das, was wir machen. Und jetzt sind wir mit diesem Namen geschlagen.
Jaja, wir haben rausgefunden, wichtiger ist, man muss einen guten Namen haben. Ist egal, ob man was macht, so wird man was. Reinhard übrigens ist der Mensch, der auch die Zeichnung des Pesthörnchens gemacht hat.
Und auch er hatte damals in seiner Mailbox schon eine Verschlüsselung. Und das ist auch der Anstoß gewesen, dass wir gesagt haben, das muss gehen. Das muss auch in Zerboros gehen.
Und von Reinhard kam der tolle Satz bei einer Veranstaltung. Der war nämlich zusammen mit Marco bei den Anfangspd's, also Public Domains immer da aus Hamburg, als Starthilfegeber des Chaos Computer Clubs, was wir immer total toll fanden, weswegen wir den Chaos Computer Club bis heute auch immer supporten. Und der sagte einer, als wir die Mailbox, das war nämlich glaube ich schon unsere zweite Veranstaltung, oder sogar unsere erste, da haben wir Mailboxen vorgestellt, rief irgendein Mailbox-Betreiber aus Paderborn drüber, so lange ich genug Pornos und Software in meiner Mailbox habe, dann läuft die richtig gut. Und Reinhard sagte einfach mit einer unnachahmlichen Freundlichkeit, nein, nein, im Gegenteil. Also Pornos und viele Programme zerstören eine Mailbox. Eine Mailbox ist zum Kommunizieren. Und er selber betrieb halt die Clinchbox, die hatte einen Datex-P-Zugang und einen Modem-Zubang, die er selber in einem Betriebssystem Mumps programmiert hat. Ein Echtzeitinterpreter, also ganz klasse, tolles System. Und Reinhard hat eine Zeit lang hier auch in Bielefeld gewohnt, über ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr fast. Und von ihm haben wir total viel gelernt. Also auch im Austausch mit ihm, wie man Mailboxen betreibt, wie man rangeht, wie man haben eben entwickelt, wie man Benutzern gegenüber tritt, dass man die nicht ankumpelt, sondern dass die eben auch manchmal lernen müssen, nein, das ist Technik, da musst du dich selber durchbriemeln. Und das war also ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Geburtshelfer für uns.
Diese Vernetzung war ja, das klang ja schon jetzt von Anfang an bei euch raus. Es war ja sozusagen mehr als jetzt nur ein praktisches Tool, sondern ihr habt das ja gleich auch sehr, sehr grundsätzlich gesehen. Und aus diesen Erfahrungen mit der Bionic habt ihr sozusagen, ja, erste Erfahrungen und vor allem praktische Erfahrungen gemacht, was so wer überhaupt ein Bedürfnis hat. Du hast vorhin diese Projekthelfer aus Indonesien genannt, die jetzt konkret die Bionic benutzt haben. Also was mich da interessieren würde, ist erstmal, wie sind die da drauf gekommen?
Das war jemand aus Bielefeld, der dort am Einsatz war. Und er hat festgestellt, dass das die günstigste Möglichkeit war mit einem sogenannten Point, wieder ein neues Wort. Und damit hat man das sogenannte Store-and-Forward-Verfahren verwendet, nämlich dass man nicht online selber in die Box reingegangen ist und sozusagen als Terminal das verwendet hat und die einzelnen Nachrichten dann gelesen hat, während der Telefonzeller rattert. Sondern man hat sich die Sachen als komprimiertes Paket bereitlegen lassen. Und dann hat das Programm, der sogenannte Point, dieses Paket auf einen Rutsch abgeholt, dann die Telefonleitung wieder geschlossen und dann ausgepackt. Und dann konnte man es in Ruhe auf dem eigenen Desktoprechner angucken. Und das ist halt auch ein Verfahren, was ermöglicht, dass sehr viele Leute so eine Mailbox, also einen Serverrechner, verwenden und da rankommen.
Weil die Verbindungszeiten sozusagen minimal sind.
Ganz genau. Die Verbindungszeit wird ganz kurz gehalten. Und das ist eine Sache, die zum einen für die dann kostengünstig war, aber uns auch in anderen Kontexten ermöglicht hat, überhaupt so was sinnvoll einzusetzen. Zum Beispiel haben wir ja später auch ein Mailbox-Netzwerk in Ex-Jugoslawien aufgebaut während des Krieges. Das war dann ab 92, also Ende 91 bis 96, haben wir dieses ZaMir Transnational Network in Ex-Jugoslawien betrieben. Und dort war es zum Beispiel schwierig, an Telefonleitungen ranzukommen. Und das System in Sarajevo, die Stadt, die drei Jahre belagert war, dort war es extrem wichtig, dieses System zu haben. Die Box dort hatte drei Telefonzugänge und 5.000 Nutzerinnen und Nutzer. Und die haben das Ding genutzt. Und das geht natürlich nicht, wenn die so etwas wie Webmail verwenden und da online dran im Ruhm vorwerken sind, sondern das geht nur mit diesem Verfahren mit einem Point. Dann kann nämlich dein Point-Programm auch nachts anrufen, sich das Paket holen und du guckst dir am nächsten Tag deine Post an.
ZaMir hieß das Projekt?
ZaMir heißt Für den Frieden. Ab 1991 war Eric Bachmann.
Habt ihr das jetzt dort installiert?
Also Eric Bachmann, der aus den USA stammt und Friedensaktivist ist, der den Kriegsdienst verweigert hat und deshalb in Deutschland gelebt hat, der hat sich schon sehr früh dort engagiert und hat dort zum Beispiel gewaltfreies Widerstandstraining gemacht für Leute und hat die Friedensgruppen dort unterstützt und zwar in allen Landesteilen. Und er war vor allem jetzt in Serbien und Kroatien unterwegs. Und er hat dann festgestellt, dass eins der größten Probleme ist, dass die Telefonleitungen blockiert wurden aus politischen Gründen. Also zwischen Serbien und Kroatien konnte man nicht mehr telefonieren. Ursprünglich wurde das dann per Fax gelöst. Also die haben dann zum Beispiel nach London Fax geschickt von Zagreb in Kroatien. Dort haben die dann das Fax wieder in die Maschine gestopft und haben dann das Fax nach Belgrad in Serbien geschickt. Das ist A, wahnsinnig teuer, B, sehr kompliziert und dann immer diese Zwischenstation. Und das geht halt mit einer Mailbox, mit einem Mailbox-Server automatisch. Und Erik hat dann angefangen, uns Löcher in den Bauch zu fragen, wie funktioniert denn so ein System, wie macht man das? Und wir haben alles nach bestem Wissen beantwortet, bis wir irgendwann auch nicht mehr wussten. Das mussten wir dann gemeinsam herausfinden. Und der ist dann rumgereist und hat dort ein System nach dem anderen aufgebaut. Die Systeme hießen alle Samir und dann das Autokennzeichen von der jeweiligen Stadt. Insofern gab es BG für Belgrad, ZA für Zagreb, SA für Sarajevo und dann gab es noch Tussler, Pristina und Lobelianer.
Eine Idee war, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es realisiert worden ist, auf beiden Seiten von Mostar.
Nein.
Nee, ist nicht. Aber es war so ein Versuch, das hinzukriegen.
Mostar ist die Stadt mit der berühmten Brücke. Ich bin selber dort gewesen. Die Spannungen sind in kaum einer Stadt so groß wie dort. Und dort war es nicht möglich, das tatsächlich durchzuziehen. Aber in anderen Städten war es, wie gesagt, sehr erfolgreich. Sie haben auch zum Teil Systeme dann in Flüchtlingslager gebracht, wo Leute dann ihre Nachrichten schreiben konnten und sie versenden. Und das war extrem wichtig. Ich bin später Leuten in Sarajevo begegnet, die darüber ihre Verwandten wiedergefunden haben. Mir ist selber dort vor Ort erst klar geworden, dass es nicht ein Projekt war, wo Computerfreaks sich toll fühlen, weil sie denken, dass sie irgendwas Wichtiges tun, sondern dass das wirklich was Extremwichtiges gewesen ist, weil die Leute sich von aller Welt verlassen gefühlt haben in dieser Situation, wo dort der Krieg tobte.
In einer Veranstaltung in Graz stand, glaube ich, mal ein Mensch aus Ex-Jugoslawien, der sagte, eigentlich müsste ein Bielefeld-Denkmal in allen Städten Ex-Jugoslawiens stehen. Das fanden wir ganz toll, haben ein Tränchen verdrückt. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier und reden mit dir, Tim. Frag was anderes, komm, wir weinen sonst.
Naja, ich meine, das ist schon...... ist ja auch mal ganz interessant. Man redet immer gerne so über diese theoretische Bedeutung und wie weitschleifig das doch alles ist. Und lädt sich dann doch wieder irgendwie ein Spiel runter und vertreibt sich damit irgendwie seine Zeit und trägt nicht wirklich so zum Weltfrieden bei. Das finde ich auch mal ganz interessant zu sehen, welche Auswirkungen es haben kann, wenn man eben die Dinge dann auch wirklich zum Einsatz bringt. Diese ganze Mailbox-Zeit wurde ja dann durch das Internet eigentlich je beendet, kann man sagen.
Alle Strukturen, die sich geschaffen hatten, wurden gnadenlos zerstört.
Es ist eigentlich irgendwie nichts mehr da. Auch die Systeme selber haben sich dann später nicht im Netz wiedergefunden. Das wurde quasi dann durch...
Ein paar gibt es tatsächlich. Die JP Berlin, die auch der großen Server ist, die zum Beispiel sehr viele Mailing-Listen von NGOs verwalten. Also, ist ein bekannter politischer Provider. Die Link M in München. Der andere ist die Link M in München, die auch sehr engagiert betrieben wird. Also, einige haben tatsächlich den Wechsel dann zum Internetprovider gemacht.
Odo Schacht Wiegand ist immer noch da. Macht die Trilos, glaube ich, jetzt in Hannover. Ja, ja, der ist da auch gemacht.
Link war doch auch so ein politisches...
Die Link-Systeme, ja. CL-Netzwerk.
Ähnlich wie Samir, da war dann Link vorne und danach dann das Autokennzeichner Link HH war für Hamburg und Link M in München, wie gesagt.
Und das war auch ein ganz spannendes Netzwerk, weil Gaby Hofacker und Peter Lok, die das so für und betrieben haben, waren auch Leute, die haben dreimal im Jahr Treffen veranstaltet, wo man als Systembetreiber, der spät auch als Teilnehmer einfach hingehen konnte und mitgestalten konnte. Man hat da überlegt, wie muss etwas abgefasst sein, wie benennt man Gruppen, damit es für Leute einfach ist, wie kann man etwas wiederfinden? Auch Tipps zu geben, wie kann ich sowas finanzieren? Das war ja leider etwas, was in Deutschland in den 60er Jahren völlig zerstört wurde, war so eine ökonomische Vorstellung davon, dass Dinge, die ich tue, auch irgendwie finanziert werden müssen. Wir hatten so eine sehr ungute Art, die haben wir zum Teil noch heute, ich merke das immer mal wieder, dass gute Dinge nichts kosten dürfen, was natürlich völliger Blödsinn ist, weil das heißt, ich bezahle nur meine Feinde, aber meine Freunde nicht. Und wir haben schon sehr früh überlegt, das muss anders sein. Und fanden das zum Beispiel ganz klasse, dass der Chaos-Kongress 100 Mark Eintritt gekostet hat. Ich glaube, es waren 100 Mark damals. Weil das einfach toll war, man hat da Geld hingetan, dann standen da acht Telefone, in denen man so viel überall hin telefonieren konnte, wo man wollte, man hatte Spaß und es war gut, und es musste keiner dafür... Ja, der war richtig teuer, gleich von Anfang an. Der erste schon. Das war richtig klasse. Das hat Steffen mit seiner großartigen Kalt-Schnurzigkeit einfach durchgesetzt und das war halt großartig.
Du meinst jetzt nicht die Presse?
Nein, nein, der hat für alle, der hat richtig Geld gekostet.
Richtig Geld, aber ob es 100 waren?
Na ja, vielleicht waren es 50, keine Ahnung. Aber setze irgendwas ein wie ganz viel und so. Ja, doch, das war schon sehr teuer.
Halten wir fest, es war viel und bei anderen Veranstaltungen war das halt nicht angesagt. Und natürlich auch die Frechheit der Presse, sozusagen mehr zu berechnen.
Stimmt, die Presse hat 100 gekostet und die anderen haben was weniger bezahlt, aber auch noch ziemlich viel.
Weil die Presse natürlich am meisten davon am Anfang auch profitiert hat, weil die interessanten Geschichten zu der Zeit halt natürlich aus der Szene kamen.
Und ich kann mich halt an Punk-Konzerte erinnern, die Hilsberg in Hamburg in einer Markthalle veranstaltet hat, wo irgendwie fünf Gruppen aufgetreten sind und man fand fünf Mark zu viel als Eintritt an solche Scherze. Also das war schon echt peinlich. Und diese ganzen komischen Technik-Freaks, die dann auch standen, nein, ich gebe meinen Rechner gratis, nein, ich nehme kein Geld dafür, ich duze alle und ich bin nett. Das war halt furchtbar, weil es hat dazu geführt, dass sich nicht eine große Szene von kleinen mittelständischen Unternehmen aufgebaut hat, die jetzt quasi örtliche Provider sind, mit denen man in zwei Zwei in die Augen gucken kann, sondern dass wir heute eine Kultur haben von, ich versuche mal da anzurufen und jemanden beim Support die Leine zu kriegen, den ich noch nie gesehen habe, nie sehen werde, der mich hasst, der nicht in der gleichen Chor singt wie ich und wir damit ja eigentlich die Chancen vertan haben, unsere Datenwelt ein bisschen freundlicher oder benutzbarer oder angenehmer oder überhaupt funktionabel einzurichten.
Beim FoeBuD ist es dann geblieben. Das war dann sozusagen ein Konstrukt, was ja bis heute überlebt hat.
Mit Wandlung einhaben.
Genau, wollte ich darauf gerade hinaus. Es gab dann schon so die Wandlung. Ich meine, es ist ja jetzt dann auch offensichtlich so dieser Mailbox-Grundversorgungsbedarf, sodass man irgendwie seine Nachbarschaft mit Digitalkommunikation versorgen muss. Das fiel dann halt einfach irgendwann weg. Ich meine, man kann das ja auch sehr positiv sehen. Das ist ja das, was wir immer alle haben wollten.
Den Job müssen wir nicht mehr machen.
Anfang der 90er-Jahre, als es auch so im Internet aufkam, da gab es ja auch andere Gruppen, was weiß ich hier so, Subnetz und so, die auch alle sich dafür eingesetzt haben, dass halt Privatleute ans Netz kommen müssen. Ich meine, heute wird den Privatleuten für jeden Supermarkt aufgelauert, dass sie ins Netz kommen. Das hat sozusagen...
Aber zu teureren Preisen.
Ja gut, aber es ist nicht mehr das Problem an sich, Kommunikation überhaupt teilnehmen zu können.
Aus der Zeit kommt aber das FoeBuD-Logo, das ist klar. Also der freundliche Computer, der nicht nur lächelt, sondern auch noch die Zunge rausstreckt. Also die...
Frech und freundlich.
Frech und freundlich die Anmutung an Albert Einstein, der halt auch die Zunge rausstreckt.
Deswegen der FoeBuD manchmal auch der Club der freundlichen Genies genannt wird.
Und damals versuchten wir halt allen Leuten begreiflich zu machen, dass es etwas Wunderbares ist, mit einem Computer halt etwas tun zu können. Und deswegen haben wir diesen Computer als Logo. Und das wäre, wenn wir jetzt nochmal drüber nachdenken und wir denken drüber nach, über neuen Namen und über ein neues Logo, dann geht es natürlich auch darum zu überlegen, welche anderen Begriffe...
Ich denke über einen neuen Namen.
Ja, wir denken über einen neuen Namen.
Nein, das ist nicht tapfer, das ist einfach professionell.
Gucken wir mal, welcher Name.
Frag mal gerade nach, deine Hörer sollen anrufen und jetzt anrufen und jetzt sagen, wie heißt dieser Verein?
Da müssen wir dann nochmal eine Live-Sendung machen. Das wäre ja nur auf Konserve hier gerade gescheitert.
Ja, die haben jetzt schon den Namen wieder vergessen. Bis auf die, die ihn zufällig schon mal auswendig gelernt haben. Und die werden ihn falsch schreiben, weil sie nicht wissen, welcher der blöden Buchstaben groß geschrieben wird.
Ich kann die Leute ja im Blog-Eintrag schon mal drauf vorbereiten, dass sie die ganze Zeit das Mikrofon mitlaufen lassen sollen.
Und sie sollen nicht an das Rosa-Nil-Fett denken.
Genau, das ist sehr wichtig. So, das war der Humor-Murteil. Wieder zu den Fragen bitte, Herr Moderator.
Ja, bleiben wir noch so ein bisschen in dieser verrückten Zeit. Ich fand sie total verrückt, weil man war ja auch...
Jung.
Jung, klar, da verdient man die Zeit immer ein bisschen verrückt. Aber sie war ja auch verrückt. Ich meine, das fang ja eben schon an, so mit der Presse, so alle lauerten einem irgendwie auf, weil da waren ja die spannenden Geschichten. Man war so Teil einer Bewegung, die sich einfach mit diesem Zeug beschäftigt hat, von dem keiner irgendwie ein paar Jahre vorher geahnt hat, dass es das überhaupt gibt. So, und dann brach auf einmal auch so ein kultureller Schwall los, ja, das Bild des bösen Hackers, beziehungsweise des jungen Kids in seinem Wohnzimmer, der irgendwie die Atomraketensilos nach Bedarf auf- und zuklappt usw. Das kennen wir alle, WarGames, diese Sachen, die halt teilweise absurd falsch waren, aber teilweise auch...
Also uns haben die immer Spaß gemacht.
Absurd zutrafen.
Wir haben nie richtig dementiert.
Es gab auf jeden Fall immer wieder so kleine Brains, die dann aber halt auch wirklich schlimmes Zeug gemacht haben. Schlimm jetzt nicht im Sinne von verboten. Das vielleicht teilweise auch, aber nur weil die Gesetzeslage komisch war, aber halt schlimm, weil sie halt auch einfach was hinbekommen haben. Allerauf wollte ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr hinaus, sondern was sich ja auch extrem verändert hat, ist die Orte, wo man sich trifft. Und einer der Orte, wo man sich ja immer traf, war die Cebit. Heutzutage gibt es die noch? Ja, genau, es ist einfach nur noch so ein Ach-ja-da.
Das heißt doch jetzt Funkausstellung und das ist in Berlin, oder?
Also genau, ich denke auch, die Cebit hat mittlerweile ihren Nimbus nahezu vollständig eingeböst, zumindest halt in dieser speziellen Computerszene. Das war halt lange Zeit total anders. Das war ja wirklich der Ort, wo man sich traf, einerseits, aber auch wo man halt die Leute traf, die sich wirklich mit diesem ganzen Scheiß beschäftigt haben, wo man dann vielleicht auch mal die Gelegenheit hatte, einen Entwickler aus Amerika zu treffen oder irgendwas Abgefahrenes. Das war ja wie eine Reise zum Mond. Ihr wart da ja auch vertreten.
Ja, wir hatten die beknackte Idee und zwar im Januar 1990. Der FoeBuD muss doch auch einen eigenen Stand auf der Cebit haben, sagte jemand von uns. Dann hat Palloun bei der Messe angerufen, weil muss man dann ja einfach machen. Die sagten, nein, viel zu spät, Cebit im März, viel zu spät. Und nein, Computercamp hieß das damals.
Wann habt ihr da angerufen?
Im Januar 1990 und im März.
1990 wollte sie dir ja gerne den Stand haben.
Und man hätte ein halbes Jahr mindestens vorher anrufen müssen, ein Dreivierteljahr oder so.
Computercamp gibt es nicht mehr, das heißt jetzt Chancen 2000. Und da gibt es keinen Platz mehr. Aber das organisiert Firma Inbit aus Paderborn. Und wir so, oh, dann rufen wir dann doch da mal an. Und siehe da, die Frau, die die Veranstaltung organisiert hat, war spontan begeistert und hat uns einen Stand freigeräumt.
Das Geile war nämlich, wir hießen FoeBuD und nicht Chaos Computer Club, weil sie hätten gerne Chaos Computer Club auf der Cebit gehabt. Ja, den darf man aber nicht auf die Cebit einladen, weil das sind die bösen Hacker. Also lädt man doch den FoeBuD ein, wo dann auch der ganze Chaos Computer Club da ist. Und insofern war das schon mal eine Bedingung hervorragend erfüllt. Das Zweite war, die Frau hatte in ihrem Studium einen sehr tollen Professor, der hieß... Helmar G. Frank. Und dieser Helmar G. Frank hat nämlich bei uns eine Veranstaltung gehalten über seine abstrusen Theorien von Copyreizer Hexenverbrennung. Und sie fand ihren Prof toll und sie fand es toll, dass es Leute gab, die den mal auch toll fanden und eine Ausstellung machen ließen. Das war der zweite Faktor. Sie fand also auch den FoeBuD toll. Und so waren wir am März dann tatsächlich auf der C-Wett.
Und das war so erfolgreich, dass wir sieben Jahre insgesamt in Folge jedes Jahr dort ein Messestand gemacht haben.
Damals war auch das Messegelände noch anders als es heute ist. Es ist extrem umgebaut worden über die Jahre, auch durch die Expo. Das war damals noch so ein freistehender Glaspavillon.
Ja, teilweise. Wir waren in verschiedenen Hallen. Das waren mehrere Hallen. Zum Schluss war es immer der kleine Glaspavillon.
Das war der schönste Ort eigentlich.
Wo wir dann einmal auch geschafft haben, die gesamte Messehalle durch einen Messeigel zu haben. Messeigel, soll ich erklären?
Ja, aber vielleicht erstmal Chancen 2000 erklären. War da nicht Nordrhein-Westfalen der eigentliche Pate?
Nein, nein, nein. Chancen 2000 war der Innovationsbereich der CeBIT. Und zwar gibt es nämlich immer Projekte, wo alle Aussteller pro Quadratmeter, den sie haben, noch einen Zusatzbeitrag bezahlen müssen für die On-Top-Projekte, die halt so gemacht werden.
Auma.
Kunstausstellungen gab es damals, was irgendwas mit Computerkunst zu tun hatte. Da gibt es die Länderausstellungen und solche Sachen.
Es ging um Förderung allein dieser Messe. Es ging darum, wie machen wir Marketing für diese Messe, weil IT will kein Mensch wissen. Wie kriegen wir Leute dahin? Wie kriegen wir das hin, dass das mehr in die Öffentlichkeit geht? Und dann gab es am Anfang irre viele Sonderausstellungen. Der zweite Trick dabei ist, dass die Messe AG auf diese Art ihren Boden verkauft kriegt, weil sie dann die AUMA-Pauschale für sich selbst anstecken kann. AUMA? AUSTELLER und Beirat oder so. Was heißt das irgendwie? Aussteller mit Bestimmungsbeirat oder so. Das ist diese sogenannte AUMA-Pauschale. Aus der wurde dann eben auch Chancen 2000 finanziert. Man versuchte dann auch, weil die Messe immer größer wurde und man brauchte die nicht mehr unterstützen, diese AUMA-Geschichten dann auch eher auf andere Sachen umzumünzen. So was wie Sonderland Brasilien stellt vor. Dann haben die dann irgendwie ein bisschen was gekriegt. Die Messe AG hat sich das Geld eingesteckt. Und Brasilien wurde dann besonders vorgestellt. Man versuchte auch tatsächlich dieses Camp, also diese Chancen 2000, auch irgendwann mal wieder wegzukriegen. Weil es wurde ja eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig gebraucht. Aber es war immer so erfolgreich, dass sie das eben nicht geschafft haben.
Woran macht ihr jetzt diesen Erfolg fest?
Der Erfolg liegt einfach darin, dass das wirklich der Treffpunkt war, wo zum einen Leute von Firmen hingekommen sind, um sich inspirieren zu lassen, um Leute zu treffen, um spannende Leute zu treffen. Und es war unglaublich viel Presse und viel Prominenz da. Also was wir an Politikerinnen und Politikern so bei uns über den Stand geschoben bekommen haben, ist irre. Und wie viele Journalisten wir kennengelernt haben zu dieser Zeit, wie viele Leute wir erklärt haben, wie ein Modem funktioniert in den frühen Zeiten und was man damit tun kann. Und das hat richtig viele Leute gezogen. Also man hat wirklich gesehen, dass diese Veranstaltung gut funktioniert und dass das Bedürfnis wirkt. Und deswegen konnten sie die Chancen 2000 nicht kippen. Und der Veranstaltungsmacher, der das dann halt übernommen hat nach dem...
Arno Evers, ja.
Arno Evers, nach dem, also ab dem zweiten Jahr, hat den FoeBud halt auch sehr geschätzt und hat gesehen, da lebt was, da passiert was, da docken ganz viele Leute an. Und das will ich haben. Und hat uns dann auch sehr viel Platz gegeben.
Wir hatten 120 Quadratmeter und wir hatten mehr.
Also einmal hatten wir 250. Das war richtig, richtig viel und konnten dann einen Café-Bereich aufbauen.
Alles ohne Kohle auf der Zielwelt. Und dann aber auch 80 Leute, die mitarbeiten und zwar freiwillig.
Das war so ein Glas-Pavillon, der so ein bisschen zum... Ich meine, das Ganze war dann irgendwann so ein bisschen das Wohnzimmer der Computerszene geworden. Das war auch immer so mein Eindruck. Abends gab es dann immer die aktuelle Vorlesung der Firmenpartys. Man musste sich ja irgendwie verpflegen.
Ja, weil da haben wir gegessen. Samstags war immer am schlimmsten, weil es da nie Feten gab. Da sind wir einmal auf die... Na ja, egal.
Samstag gab es immer die Pressehalbzeit-Party.
Stimmt, das war dann... Ach, der Sonntag war die Hölle. Die Pressehalbzeit war... Ich weiß noch, wie sie Peter Hänel samt Stuhl rausgetragen haben.
Es war auch so ein heimlicher Krieg, muss man sagen, zwischen der Computerszene und der CeBIT.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Irgendwann hat die CeBIT dann gewonnen, aber bis dahin musste sie viel in der Lage machen.
Ja, aber die CeBIT hat auf der ganzen Linie verloren dabei. Also wir waren ja auch nicht mehr interessiert. Insofern war das nicht ein großer Sieg, aber wir sind auch heute noch zum Teil freundschaftlich verbunden. Aber das Spannende, gerade wurde das erzählt, mit diesen Party-Verlesungen, das war ja dann der Messe-Igel. Das war so, dass wir beim ersten Stand, den wir gemacht haben, da haben wir dann gesehen, dass die da irgendwo stehen und sich so gegenseitig empowern.
So, Herr Müller-Schwilfer hat heute Aufträge im Wert von, weiß nicht, 5000 Euro geschrieben. So jetzt aber mal Beifall für.
Und wir werden das morgen alle schaffen. Morgen sind wir richtig toll. Wie sind wir? Ja, wir sind richtig toll und so was.
Und das haben wir halt mitgekriegt. Wir standen da halt.
Und wir die Kettenlade runter.
Wir hatten halt Siemens neben uns und ich weiß nicht was. Du stehst da irgendwie mit deinem kleinen Stand bei der allerersten Messe 1990.
Wir haben ihn geschickt vergrößert.
Aber ihr habt zumindest nicht eure Verkäufe bejubelt.
Nein, aber dann haben wir halt genau das parodiert.
Wir haben uns dann immer in so einen Kreis gestellt. Und dann so leicht wie beim Eishockey.
Nächsten Spielzug besprechen.
Und leicht in die Knie gehen. Und dann rief ich dann immer, wie sind wir? Und dann alle, Spitze! Was wollen wir?
Umsatz! Umsatz!
Und jetzt erzähle ich euch etwas, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dieser nette Herr, der uns da gerade interviewt, dieser Tim Pritlove, der ist jahrelang immer dazugekommen und hat den großen Kreiskoordinator gemacht. Weil es blieb nicht bei einem kleinen Kreis. Der Kreis wurde immer größer. Irgendwann hatten wir und das lag natürlich auch mit daran, weil wir vorher, bevor wir gebrüllt haben, auch immer verlesen haben, wann welche Party auf dem Messegelände war, strömten dann kurz vor 18 Uhr die Massen in die Halle. Ein riesengroßer Kreis durch die ganze Messehalle. Ich weiß noch, einmal war Jürgen Trittin mit dabei. Tim, der damals leidenschaftlicher Inline-Skater war, raste immer durch die Halle und sorgte dafür, dass der Kreis ordentlich und war.
Es war wirklich ein Drama mit diesem Kreis. Also es war halt einfach keiner.
Und Tim war der große Kreiskoordinator. Und das hat sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und dieser Messeigel ist tatsächlich, also hin und wieder hört man noch davon, aber so, ja.
Das war auf jeden Fall eine extrem lustige Veranstaltung. Und ja, es war dann auch Wohnzimmer. Es war wirklich so der Ort, wo die Cebit dann auch angenehm wurde. Weil es war ja ansonsten war es ja einfach mal total ätzend, da durch die Hallen zu laufen. Und ja, wenn man heute auf die Cebit geht, hat man halt nur noch ätzend.
Naja, wir nicht.
Man muss ja auch nicht mehr gehen.
Also wir gehen tatsächlich einmal noch immer auf die Cebit, weil wir einmal den Heisestand besuchen und einmal Freunde von uns besuchen, die dort für eine der größeren Firmen Aufbauten machen und sehr tolle Aufbauten machen. Und das ist dann eigentlich auch. Und fangst du mir noch zu, wenn ich an etwas Interessantes vorbeikomme.
Aber auch das Internet hat natürlich diesem Ort seinen Wert genommen jetzt so für die Szene.
Nein, ich glaube, sowas wie eine...
Das spricht mir nicht.
Doch, selbstverständlich, Tim. Das habe ich immer getan und wir können auch streiten.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Warum nicht? Dann kriegen die Leute mal mit, wie es richtig ist. Wusstet ihr, dass manchmal sowas auch Schreitherapie genannt wird? Also, dieses Begingeln von Menschen ist sowas von unglaublich wichtig. Und Netz kann es nur unterstützen. Es kann vorbereiten, es kann organisieren, es kann auch mal tatsächlich zum Kontakt genutzt werden. Aber ohne das persönliche Treffen geht es gar nicht. Und das ist bis heute zu merken. Ich habe also gerade wieder das schöne Erlebnis gehabt, bevor der Arbeitskreis Zensur sich komplett zerlegt hat, hat man sich in Hattingen getroffen und mal zusammengesetzt und dann ging es wieder. Und das braucht es einfach. Und auch so etwas wie eine CeBIT, auch mit ihren Aufbauten, auch mit den Leuten, denen die dazukommen. Diese Ernsthaftigkeit, dieses Celebrieren, was man da macht, ist einfach wichtig, auch um Business mit den Leuten untereinander zu machen. Also für uns war auf der CeBIT toll. Wir hatten ja unser Telefon, unser kleines Büro im Hintergrund. Und dann hat man eben mal Sven Kigas von Novell angerufen und gesagt, komm mal vorbei, wir zeigen dir was. Und dann hat er sich da Modem angeguckt und fand das toll oder so. Das ist eine ganz andere Sache und die lässt sich durch Internet oder Anklicken einer Website und konzentriert irgendwo gelangweilt drüber hinwegklicken, überhaupt nicht ersetzen. Und insofern habe ich da ja, habe ich diesen Satz von Gabriele Hofacker, den sie geprägt hat, erst reisen die Daten, dann die Menschen nach wie vor im Kopf und finde es unglaublich wichtig, dass wir in unserer Kommunikationsgesellschaft, die eben keine Informationsgesellschaft nur ist, sondern eine Kommunikationsgesellschaft, das Reisen ganz stark im Vordergrund stehen muss. Wie man ja auch an deiner Bahnkarte 100 sieht. Hättest du vor zehn Jahren gedacht, dass du mit einer Bahnkarte 100 durch Deutschland fahren würdest, um Leute direkt zu sehen, statt über mal eben schnell ein Telefoninterview zu machen?
Na ich glaube vor zehn Jahren konnte ich mir fast gar nichts von dem vorstellen, was ich jetzt mache. Na ja, ganz stimmt das jetzt auch nicht, aber das ist ja nicht so wichtig. Was mich noch interessieren würde, ist, wie habt ihr denn so das Verhältnis gesehen vom FoeBuD zum Club, zum CCC?
Unterschiedlich. Also einmal ist es so, dass wir gerade in den Anfangsjahren uns immer verstanden haben als jemand, der diesen Club supporten will, weil wir es toll fanden. Und zwar eine gewisse Form von Dankbarkeit, also einmal wegen dieser Veranstaltung 2005, die hier gemacht wurde und wegen das... Nein, hier, Galerie.
1985.
1985, Entschuldigung. Und das zweite eben, dieses Supporten vom... unserer Veranstaltung und FoeBuD, also was über Reiner Schrutzki und Marco, die halt auch immer herkamen und das mit unterstützt haben, dass sich hier was aufbaut, das fanden wir halt ganz toll. Wir fanden, wie gesagt, auch diese ganze Szene sehr spannend und auch die Leute da drin. Man muss sich halt die Hacker von damals als sehr freundliche Menschen vorstellen, also weit entfernt von...
Anders als heute.
Anders als heute, ja. Wo auch Mobbing und Schreitherapie Begriffe sind, die dicht nebeneinander liegen. Es bessert sich gerade. Was guckst du so tief? Und das...
Wir haben uns dann sehr auch vor allem bei dem Korgress engagiert und der war damals noch in Hamburg. Also der Chaos Communication Kongress lief damals im Eidlstädter Bürgerhaus in Hamburg und es sind dann sehr viele Bielefelder auch mitgekommen und haben alle irgendwo an ihrer Stelle halt gearbeitet. Zum Teil in dem Pressezentrum, zum Teil in der Küche, zum Teil in der Projektleitung.
Damals wurde noch auf dem Kongress selber gekocht, meine Herren. Das war richtig klasse, ja.
Als er sah, dass Papillon fast vom Stuhl gefallen ist, von Müdigkeit und noch die Kartoffeln fertig machen wollte.
Es gab tatsächlich eine Zeit, wo irgendwann so war, dass ein Teil, also eigentlich der CCC in Bielefeld war, eigentlich nur noch getragen durch Andi im Hamburg. Also wir haben dann halt irgendwie versucht, das aufrecht zu erhalten. Wau war irgendwie nach Heidelberg rüber gemacht. Er hatte das nicht ertragen, der große Hacker sein zu müssen, also diese öffentliche Aufgabe auch wahrnehmen zu müssen, diese Verantwortung dazu tragen. Und dann eitelte der Club im Grunde so vor sich hin. Und man schaffte halt immer diesen einen Kongress, hat man noch hinbekommen, sich auch immer, wenn man mal durch Hamburg fuhr, dann im Club getroffen, was toll war, aber es waren wenig Macher da, die es dann so mehr in die Hand nahmen. Ja, und Steffen halt, also Steffen, Andi und wir beide. Und das war im Grunde eine Zeit lang der CCC, bis sich das dann auch wieder gewandelt hat.
Ich glaube, so eine tote Phase Anfang der 90er-Jahre.
Ja, da war so ein bisschen die Luft raus. Und wir haben dann sehr viel inhaltliche Sachen reingebracht, also so gesellschaftliche und politische Sachen, was irgendwann mal dazu führte, dass wir bei einer Mitgliederversammlung haben und auch sagten, ihr müsst mal was gegen uns tun, damit es für euch auch wieder interessant wird. Weil zu viel von diesem komischen gesellschaftlichen, politischen Krempel macht dann einfach auch keinen Spaß mehr, weil dazu gehört auch hecken und Lötkäumen in die Hand nehmen und böse Dinge tun und nicht nur das nette, freundliche, politische zu machen. Und das hat dann auch nicht mehr so ganz richtig gestimmt. Und wir waren halt schon auch immer da sehr, ich glaube, ganz schön stark in dem, wie wir auch Leute angesprochen haben und reingebracht haben. Plötzlich ging dann irgendwie, waren auf dem Kongress dann auch Messebekanntschaften, also irgendwelche Unternehmensleiter, die es halt klasse fand, auf dem Kongress zu sein, die auch selber was reingebracht haben mit, die dann halt keiner kannte, aber wir halt. Also wir haben da schon sehr früh in dem, speziell im Kongress, eine Keimzelle, ja, klingt jetzt so blöd, von innovativen Deutschland gesehen. Tatsächlich ist es uns passiert, dass, ich weiß gar nicht, das war, glaube ich, schon beim ersten Mal, dass wir auf der CeBIT ausstellten. Da kam eine Frau in unserem Stand vorbei, so hektischen Schrittes, blieb stehen, guckte uns an, guckte so rum, erfasste irgendwie, was wir machen, sagte, was machen Sie hier? Und dann kurz erklärt, ich muss da morgen mehr darüber wissen. Und dann kam sie am nächsten Tag wieder hin. Und das war die Chefin, also nicht die politische, sondern die Verwaltungschefin, irgendwie des Wirtschaftsministeriums aus Luxemburg. Und die wollte wissen, wie schafft man es, dass junge Leute mit den Themen an einem Messestand stehen, so ausstehen, als hätten sie Ahnung, nicht gelangweilt sind, selber was vorstellen, selber machen. Und das dann nicht nur auf einer blöden technischen Ebene. Also das ist ein Modemstopf, das hält man an, sondern noch geistig weiterentwickelt. Sie wollte wissen, wie macht man sowas. Und ich habe ihr damals geraten, ja, da müssen sie halt gucken, dass sie in Luxemburg einen Chaos-Computer-Club gründen. Und sie lachte dann sehr. Und mir war halt von Anfang an sehr, sehr klar, dass das, was da passiert, diese Menschen, die da zusammenkommen, unter dem Logo Chaos-Computer-Club ganz wichtig sind. Und letztendlich, der FoeBuD hätte auch Chaos-Computer-Club Bielefeld geheißen, wenn wir uns damals, als er gegründet war, da war der CCC halt schon berühmt durch den BTX-Hack. Und wir wollten uns einfach nicht mit fremden Federn schmücken. Und deswegen hatten wir uns nicht Chaos-Computer-Club genannt, Bielefeld, sondern einfach anders halt FoeBuD. Und ich glaube, das war auch ganz gut, weil wir hatten uns dann schon gesehen, wir sind dann eher die, die mal eine Krawatte anziehen. Oder auch Rena und ich ganz bewusst gesagt haben, wir lernen nicht programmieren, wir machen andere Sachen. Das nenne ich zwar heute manchmal, weil ich ein bisschen sehr abhängig bin. Aber ich glaube, es war auch ganz wichtig, andere Sachen machen zu können. Aber das weißt du ja wahrscheinlich sehr. Du kannst ja beides programmieren und andere Sachen.
Ja, genau. Dann kommen wir doch wieder zurück zum FoeBuD. Ihr habt da dann eigentlich eine andere Richtung eingeschlagen. Das war nicht die richtige Bezeichnung, finde ich. Es hat sich dann auf jeden Fall ein neuer Weg ergeben, nachdem diese ganze Kommunikationsgeschichte eh nicht mehr aktuell war. Heute steht der FoeBuD in der Öffentlichkeit anders da, finde ich. Einerseits ein bisschen als Bürgerrechtsbewegung oder Teil einer Bürgerrechtsbewegung zumindest. Ihr seid ja jetzt aktiv bei solchen Aktionen wie der Demo, Freiheit statt Angst und so weiter. Und natürlich auch, und ich denke, in der Medienöffentlichkeit mittlerweile auch vor allem durch die Big Brother Awards-Geschichte, die ihr einmal im Jahr hier für Deutschland macht, nicht alleine macht, sondern mit dem CCC zusammen macht, noch mit zwei, drei anderen Organisationen. Mir fallen jetzt gerade wieder alle nicht ein, aber du kannst ja gerne mal aufzählen, wer da alles mitwirkt.
Gib mir eine Website, nein, das sind...
FITUG, die Humanistische Union, die Deutsche Vereinigung für Datenschutz.
Internationale Liga für Menschenrechte und...
Die andere unvergessliche Organisation.
DVD, Deutsche Vereinigung für Datenschutz. Ach so, die kann man ruhig zweimal erwähnen, die sind klasse.
Okay, also ihr habt da so ein Bündnis geschmiedet, auf jeden Fall. Und das Ganze findet immer, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer so sein wird, aber fand bisher immer im Bielefeld statt.
Und fand bisher immer im Herbst statt. Und wir sind über alle Sachen am Nachdenken, denn das war jetzt zehn Jahre. Wir haben also 2000 angefangen mit den Big Brother Awards. Und das war für uns auch die Entscheidung, die den Einfluss, den wir vorher hatten, dadurch, dass wir Zerberos Software und auch zum Beispiel die Übertragungsprotokolle, Z Connect und so weiter, zu der Zeit konnten wir noch Einfluss nehmen vorher, um Kommunikation zu kanalisieren und zum Beispiel Überwachung schwerer zu machen. Wir haben auch uns für PGP eingesetzt, also Pretty Good Privacy, das Verschlüsselungsprogramm für private E-Mail. Und haben das Handbuch dafür herausgegeben. Wir haben 12.000 Exemplare davon verkauft tatsächlich im Selbstverlag. Das ist richtig viel.
Das war auch lange Zeit eigentlich so das einzige Dokument, das es dazu gab.
Das Standardwerk zu dieser E-Mail-Verschlüsselung. Und wir haben also auf diesem Wege versucht, via Software und Standards Einfluss zu nehmen. Und das war dann eben mit Internet, explosionsartiger Ausbreitung, AOL, gratis CDs in jedem Briefkasten und so weiter einfach nicht mehr drin. Und für uns waren die Big Brother Awards dann die Möglichkeit, auf einer anderen Ebene, eben auf der Ebene Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, das Thema Datenschutz, Bürgerrechte auf einer anderen Ebene rumzubringen. Und auch im breiterem Rahmen nicht nur für Kommunikationsstrukturen, sondern die Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft ist ja auch ansonsten sehr weit vorangeschritten. Es gibt eben nicht nur Digitalisierung von Telefonverbindungen, statt Hupdrehwählern in der Vermittlung bei der Post, sondern es gibt eben auch elektronische Buchungen von Reisen und so weiter. Es gibt Kundenkarten und es wird sehr viel mehr elektronisch gezahlt und online bestellt und so weiter.
Scoring-Systeme, also all dieses ganze Bestiarium der Überwachungsgesellschaft.
Und damit greift es in alle Bereiche des Lebens ein. Und deswegen war es auch genau richtig, auf eine andere Ebene zu gehen, das zu vermitteln.
Big Brother Awards sind ja nicht in Deutschland gestartet.
1998 in Großbritannien. Das ist eine Idee von Simon Davis von Privacy International. Und 99 hat eine Journalistin, Christiane Schulz-Geradotti, einen Artikel schreiben wollen mit einem Bericht darüber.
Weil die Österreicher nämlich in 99 auch übernommen hatten.
Und dann hatte sie sich überlegt, verdammt, warum gibt es sowas nicht in Deutschland? Und dann hat sie bei uns angerufen und hat gefragt. Und dann saßen wir zufällig gerade zu dritt zusammen und haben gesagt, warum eigentlich nicht? Ja, gute Idee, ja, machen wir. Und dann hat sie das auch gleich in den Artikel geschrieben. FoeBuD sagt, machen wir. Und wir hatten dann auch gleich noch dazu gesagt, wir wollen das aber nicht alleine machen, sondern wir wollen halt andere Organisationen mit ihrem Know-how und ihrer Sichtweise daran beteiligen und hatten unter anderem schon den Chaos Computer Club und Deutsche Vereinigung für Datenschutz und FIF und so weiter aufgezählt.
Der CCC war erstmal ganz böse, weil das stand auf intern.
Datenschutz ist doch nicht unsere Kernkompetenz und eigentlich spielen wir doch lieber mit der Technik und ist doch ganz toll, wenn man an alles rankommt.
Damals waren ganz viele dabei, die aus den Unix-Linux-Installationsgruppen dazugekommen waren, aber das hat uns dann schon etwas amüsiert. Mein Gott, einer der Gründe, warum wir bei CCC waren, war halt auch Datenschutz, um etwas mitzukriegen. Aber das war schon ganz lustig, das Selbstverständnis damals. Und das hat sich Gott sei Dank auch wieder sehr, sehr schön gewandelt.
Mit den Big Brother Awards geht ihr ja auf eine Art und Weise an die Öffentlichkeit ran, die jetzt so, ich weiß nicht, gibt es ein ähnliches Beispiel davor. Man hat sich eigentlich vorher immer sehr in seiner eigenen Szene bewegt und aus der Szene heraus Öffentlichkeit erzeugt. Also sowas wie der Kongressstrahl hat eine gewisse Abstrahlungskraft, aber er hat diese Abstrahlungskraft sozusagen komplett aus sich selbst heraus, aber ist natürlich irgendwie schon auch auf sich fokussiert. Es ist keine Veranstaltung für die Öffentlichkeit. Ich war jetzt auch bei eurer 10-Jahres-BBA-Geschichte da. Da war ja ganz offensichtlich, dass das schon auch eine Inszenierung ist. Das ist eine gerade eine Celebrierung, natürlich dann auch das Ausleben dieser Idee mit Preis für eigentlich hochgradig preisunwürdiges Verhalten auszugeben. Das hat ja auch sozusagen nochmal so einen eigenen Witz. Und mit dieser Inszenierung treibt man das ja dann auch nochmal so ein bisschen auf die Spitze. Was sind denn so eure Erfahrungen der Wahrnehmung dieser Medienöffentlichkeit? Wie ist die genauso oder anders geworden im Vergleich zu dem, was ihr vorher gemacht habt? Wenn ihr auf der CeBIT steht und euer Ding macht, dann ist das das eine. Aber mit der Sache wird man ja auch anders angefasst, oder?
Ja, wir haben eine Möglichkeit gefunden, Journalisten, die drüber schreiben wollen, ihren Redakteuren beizubringen, dass sie für diesen Artikel sie auch bezahlen und beauftragen. Das hat funktioniert als Transportmedium. Und das wird dankend angenommen, nach wie vor. Ich hätte auch gedacht, nach zehn Jahren ist das tot. Und plötzlich keiner mehr darum kümmern. Aber nein, das ist nicht so. Mit der Anstrengung, die wir da natürlich auch reinstecken, funktioniert das weiterhin. Und eine ganz spannende Ebene ist für mich dazu gekommen, nämlich zu streamen. Also dass wir nicht mehr darauf warten, dass Phoenix irgendwann mal vorbeikommt und aus unserer Veranstaltung irgendeinen unwesentlichen Teil rausschneidet und 20 Minuten davon sendet. Sondern wir können zwei Stunden lang im Internet streamen. Dass das funktioniert, dass wir dieses Jahr auch mit mehreren Kameras, also richtig wie eine Fernsehsendung aufgenommen und mit sehr viel Profi- und Line-Unterstützung. Und da kommt noch mal eine Ebene hinzu, die ich noch mal richtig klasse finde.
Aber wie nimmt die Öffentlichkeit jetzt das wahr, was dann die Presse, also ich rede jetzt gar nicht mehr so von den Medien selbst, sondern mehr das, was man ja eigentlich versucht, anzusprechen.
Also ich denke, wir haben geschafft wirklich bestimmte Themen in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, die vorher unbekannt waren oder völlig unterbelichtet. Also in den 90ern konntest du niemand hinterm Ofen hervorholen zum Thema Datenschutz. Das war dann irgendwie in 80er-Jahren gelaufen mit Angst vor Big Brother und 1984 und so, da hat das alles abgehakt. Jetzt ist Internet erstmal machen, keine Ahnung, wieso die meine Daten wissen wollen, was die von uns hoffen. Ja, keine Ahnung, wie die den Dienst finanzieren. Also einfach erstmal machen, alles andere ist uncool nachzufragen. Und uns war wichtig auch zu zeigen, es geht nicht nur um den Start. Deswegen war unser Hauptgewinner im allerersten Award im Jahr 2000 war Payback, die Kundenkarte, also das Ding, was Leute freiwillig nehmen, Spaß haben, Punkte sammeln, Geld sparen, wie sie denken. Natürlich ist der Rabatt vorher aufgeschlagen und das ist große Augenwischerei. Und das ist richtig eingeschlagen. Das Thema ist wirklich rumgegangen. Und etliche andere, die wir gesetzt haben, auch zum Beispiel das Thema Scoring. Das war vorher komplett unbekannt. Im Jahr 2001 war das einer der wichtigen Gewinner. Neben Otto Schiele natürlich. Gibt es weitere Unternehmen? Scoring bedeutet für jeden Menschen in Deutschland gibt es eine Zahl, einen Scorewert. Und der gibt wieder, wie wünschenswert jemand als Kundin oder Kunde ist. Und die werden von verschiedenen Unternehmen errechnet, nach Kriterien, die sie nicht offenlegen. Die sind Betriebsgeheimnis. Und darin sind unter anderem die sozio-demografischen Daten erfasst. Also in welchem Bundesland wohnt jemand, auch wie alt du bist. Da aber auch Wechsel vom Job, Wechsel vom Wohnort, in welcher Straße genau du wohnst. Und dann auch vor Google Street View sind Unternehmen mit Kameras rumgefahren und haben Häuser fotografiert und sind dann in einem Index erfasst worden. Zum Beispiel bei Firma Schober, wo man dann sehen kann, ist ein Haus in einem guten Zustand oder fällt da der Putz von der Wand. Und das sind alles Dinge, die in diesen ScoreVet mit eingehen können. Genauso wie das Zahlungsverhalten deiner Nachbarin. Nämlich wenn die keine Daten über dich vorliegen haben, verwenden sie eben nach dem Motto gleich und gleich gesell sich gern. Nehmen sie an, dass du sich so verhältst wie die Leute in deiner Nachbarschaft. Also kurzgefasst, Scoring ist ein ganz großes Vorurteilssystem, das automatisiert ist und das darf eigentlich gar nicht sein, dass das ein Scorewert die einzige Entscheidungsgrundlage ist, sondern eigentlich muss immer eine weitere Grundlage hinzukommen. Aber bei Webshops zum Beispiel wird sehr oft Scoring eingesetzt, um zu entscheiden, welche Zahlungsmöglichkeiten werden dir angeboten. Darfst du auf Rechnung bezahlen oder nur gegen Vorkasse? Oder wirst du überhaupt beliefert? Es sind Geschichten gehört worden von Leuten, die in derselben Straße wohnen, wie in der Justizvollzugsanstalt, und die dann einfach mal gar nicht beliefert werden, und wo dann ein Server-Error angezeigt wird und man leider nicht bestellen kann. Das sind die Auswirkungen von Scoring.
Vielleicht noch ein Beispiel. Lass mich gerade noch ein Beispiel hinzufügen. Hotline von E+, ich nehme das immer sehr gerne. Da ruft jemand an, kommt sofort durch. Er ruft wieder an, kommt sofort durch. Sein Kumpel ruft an, er kommt nicht durch. Gar nicht. Nie. Wann immer er anruft, er kommt nicht durch.
Du musst erst mal zehn Minuten Musik hören.
Und das bedeutet, der eine ist halt Dekunde, weil er halt da und dort lebt. Also, weil irgendeine Zahl über ihn sagt, er ist jetzt halt nicht so erwünscht. Und der andere ist ein A-Kunde. Der kann sich auch vordringeln, selbst wenn da vor ihm noch fünf andere Dekunden stehen. Und das ist hochgradig böse. Also, ich glaube, das möchte keiner, dass er so behandelt wird und wo er auch noch nicht mal was machen kann. Es ist ein technisches System. Man ist dem völlig ausgeliefert.
Das ist unabhängig davon, ob du selber deine Rechnung pünktlich bezahlst.
Und das muss eigentlich verboten werden.
Ich registriere jetzt natürlich klar eure Empörung. Und das ist ja sozusagen auch etwas, was den FoeBud schon immer ausgemacht hat. Aber was die Gesellschaft auch immer ausgemacht hat, ist, dass es ihr eigentlich scheißegal ist. Und darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen hinaus. Solche Themen, die jetzt dann auch im Rahmen des BBA-Medien-Kompatibel dargereicht werden, es gibt irgendwie einen Anlass, also ja, auch der engagierte Journalist kann sich dann mal gegenüber seiner Redaktion durchsetzen, dass ein Thema aufgegriffen wird, was vielleicht sonst links liegen gelassen worden wäre. Aber wie kommt es dann in der Gesellschaft? Also habt ihr Erfahrungen gesammelt, wo ihr sagen könnt, so, jetzt hat es auch über das, darüber berichtet wurde hinaus, auch eine Erwirkung gehabt, dass irgendwie die Gesellschaft anfängt, darüber nachzudenken.
Medorn ist weg vom Fenster. Den wollte man aus ganz anderen und richtig vernünftigen Gründen schassen und hat es nicht geschafft. Der Datenschutz hat ihn gekillt. Andere Aufsichtsräte bei anderen Firmen sind auch gegangen worden. Also das ist in den höchsten Etagen angekommen. Und das ist für mich sozusagen das allerwichtigste Zeichen, weil da geht es richtig um Macht und um Geld. Und da hat sich jemand auch richtig gewährt, mit auch Mitteln, die einem normalen Menschen nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Und er musste gehen, wegen eines Datenschutzproblems, weil er Leute beschnüffelt hat. Und da sehe ich, da haben wir was geschafft, was vor einigen Jahren undenkbar war, wo jeder nur müde gelächelt hätte. Die hätten schnüffeln können. Also sie haben ja schon immer geschnüffelt. Und wir kennen ja nun auch die damals schon zu graue Postzeiten, wie sehr auch in Unternehmen, man nennt es glaube ich intern, immer die Betriebsstasi oder Betriebsgestapo sogar, die dort am Werke war. Und mittlerweile ist das ein Aufreger und bringt Leute dazu zu reagieren.
Einschließlich der Politik.
Ich meine, dass AGBs geändert werden müssen an einigen Stellen, geht auf die Big Brother Awards zurück. Also wir nennen das auch AGB Graffiti. Also wir haben einige Spuren hinterlassen. Zum Beispiel musste Payback die AGBs ändern. Dann haben wir entdeckt, dass die bei unserem Big Brother Award-Preisträger Metro AG nicht nur wie angekündigt in ihrem Future Store in Rheinberg einige Produkte gechipt hatten, sondern sie hatten heimlich auch die Payback-Kundenkarte von diesem Extra-Markt in Rheinberg gechipt. Und dafür wurde es herausgefunden. Und das war ein großer Skandal. Metro musste einen Rückzieher machen und diese verwanzten Karten zurückziehen. Und das war ein Riesenerfolg. Und das war für viele Leute auch so ein Auslöser zu sehen, hey, ich kann doch was tun, weil diese vorherrschende Stimmung von wegen, die machen eh was sie wollen, kann ich als Einzelner gar nichts dran ändern. Dagegen sind wir auch angetreten. Und an vielen Stellen haben wir tatsächlich einzelne Erfolge. Und manchmal dauert es länger. Chibo zum Beispiel haben in ihrer Datenschutzbestimmung drinstehen, die ihre Kundendaten werden vertraulich behandelt. Sie werden grundsätzlich nicht an unberechtigte Dritte außerhalb des Unternehmens weitergegeben. Fühlen Leute sich sicher sehr zu Unrecht, denn grundsätzlich ist anders als umgangssprachlich im juristischen, heißt das, es gibt Ausnahmen. Und die unberechtigten Dritten, also da gibt es dann halt berechtigte Dritte. Chibo direkt hat seine Kundendaten über AZ direkt, eine Bertelsmann-Dochter auf dem kommerziellen Adressmarkt angeboten. Und zwar angereichert mit Alter, Wohnortgröße, Kaufkraft und Versandhandelsneigung. Wenn das Leute wüssten, die diese Formel da sehen und denken, alles prima, die geben grundsätzlich meine Daten nicht an unberechtigte Dritte weiter. Das mag zwar noch legal sein, aber wir fanden, es zieht Leute über den Tisch. Und zwar wissentlich. Das stand in der Zeitung, das ist an vielen Stellen aufgetaucht. Es hat aber ein paar Jahre gedauert, bis Thibaut, so wurde mir jetzt berichtet, dann endlich einen Rückzieher gemacht hat und gesagt hat, jetzt wird uns die Stimmung zu heiß. Wir machen das nicht mehr, die Daten werden nicht mehr verkauft. Und diese Entwicklung kann man an anderen Stellen auch sehen. Wir haben an vielen Stellen auch auf Probleme hingewiesen, wo Leute am Arbeitsplatz bespitzelt werden. Wir hatten die Lidl-Geschichte zum Beispiel schon sehr lange vorher. Und einige andere auch. Und man kann jetzt sehen, dass Leute dann sich auch trauen, auszupacken, dass Leute, dass Journalisten von sich aus recherchieren und nicht erst warten, dass ein Big Brother Award dazu rauskommt, sondern da passiert einfach viel. Und das sind zum Teil Sachen, die Jahre her sind und die jetzt aber ans Licht kommen. Und das, würde ich schon sagen, ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass das Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung sich ändert und Leute sagen, das ist Unrecht, das will ich nicht. Und dagegen tue ich jetzt auch was.
Und immerhin, wir haben einen Wahlkampf erlebt, in der die eine oder andere Partei auf das Bürgerrechtsthema gesetzt hat als ein Thema, um damit punkten zu können. Ob es jetzt zum Segen der Wochen ist, das müssen wir noch sehen.
Aber da werden wir dranbleiben.
Wir haben eine Justizministerin, die im Moment gerade gegen sich selber eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt hat. Na ja, sie wird es nicht. Am 15. Dezember 2009 ist ja eine mündliche Verhandlung. Und da hatte sie dann angekündigt, dass sie nicht auf der Klägerseite aus Ehrfurcht vor ihrem Amt sitzen wird, aber sie wird da sein.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sprichst du hier. Ganz genau. Jetzt kommen wir langsam zum Ende. Eins würde mich noch mal interessieren. Ihr seid ja jetzt da mit dem Big Brother Award und eigentlich auch mit dem, was ihr generell tut und immer getan habt. Natürlich immer so ein bisschen auch in der Rolle desjenigen, der sich beklagt, anprangert, Missstände aufzeigt. Das ist eine große Komponente. Man das jetzt mal umdreht und fragt, was ist denn der positive Blick? Was für eine Gesellschaft habt ihr denn eigentlich im Auge? Was wünscht ihr euch denn sozusagen? Was wäre für euch ein befriedigender Verlauf in der innergesellschaftlichen Entwicklung? Wie man denn nun mit dem Digitalen und den Daten, und wir wissen ja alle, da ist etwas auch im Lauf, was sich nicht jetzt so bremsen lässt. Es ist immer nur eine Frage, wie man dazu steht. Was wünscht ihr euch denn sozusagen? Was ist denn da eure Vision?
Das hat sich eigentlich gar nicht geändert zu dem, was wir vorher verfolgt haben, als wir versucht haben, die Kanäle, über die Menschen kommunizieren, halt angenehm zu gestalten. Wir möchten, dass Menschen sich frei entfalten können, dass wir in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft leben, wo sich viele beteiligen, sich angenommen fühlen und ein lebenswertes Leben haben. Und dann müssen wir einige weitere Anstrengungen für Unternehmen. Das kommt nämlich nicht von selber, genauso wie uns Bürgerrechte nicht geschenkt werden. Dann müssen wir uns auch für Gerechtigkeit und Solidarität einsetzen.
Das sieht vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen anders aus als das, was wir uns vor 15 Jahren ausgedacht haben. Wir wollten immer einen Mediencafé aufbauen, also einen Ort, einen Treffpunkt, wo Leute A, ihren Netzzugang kriegen, wo sie sich aber auch mit Leuten, die sie kennengelernt haben, in den Netzen treffen können, wo es was Angenehmes zu essen gibt, was Gutes zu trinken, wo ich Hilfe bekomme, wo ich auch einen Arbeitsplatz habe, also sowas wie so ein Hub. Also so Teile davon gibt es ja. Aus dem Mediencafé ist leider nur so ein Internetcafé geworden. Also sprich, irgendwelche Spelunken in Bahnhofsnähe mit Billigtelefon und prostituierten Neigung. Das ist für uns sehr, sehr bedauerlich. Wir haben ganz viele Konzepte damals entwickelt, wie wir Netze gestalten wollen, wie wir eine Netzgesellschaft, eine Kommunikationsgesellschaft gestalten wollen. Trotz der vielen Politiker, die über unseren Messestand hinübergeschoben wurden, hat das nirgendwo Widerhall gefunden. Also die öffentlichen Gelder, die hätten fließen müssen, um das aufzubauen, um die Modelle dafür zu entwickeln, die hat es nicht gegeben. Die Möglichkeit daraus, Fanschreising-Projekte zu generieren, hat es einfach nicht gegeben. Es gab kein Geld, die Leute konnten sich das aber auch einfach nicht richtig vorstellen. Und heute wühlen wir da so ein bisschen in der Kloake und müssen halt rausfinden, was ist noch da, was kann man verwenden. Und einiges hat sich verändert. Ich selber war z.B. schockiert, als jemand wie Lena Simon oder Franziska Heine einfach sagten, gedruckte Zeitungen interessieren mich nicht. Mich interessieren nur Online-Medien, weil die gedruckten Zeitungen wird es irgendwann bald nicht mehr geben und dann haben die ja Pech gehabt. Also, während für mich noch gedruckte Zeitungen was ganz Tolles sind. Und ich nun feststelle, ja, wir müssen auch unsere Gedanken von damals rüber transportieren, aber wir haben noch ganz viel. Aus den Zeiten, als man noch die Möglichkeit hatte, eine Kommunikationsmedien in Gänze zu erfassen, also mit den Leuten dahinter, mit den Treffen dahinter, mit der Technik, mit den Netzwerkprotokollen. Aus dieser Zeit haben wir immer noch ein irrsinniges Vorwissen, was heute eben völlig fehlt. Was nur transponiert, im Grunde transponiert werden müsste und dann auch eben in Forschungsprojekte einfließen müsste, wie wir unsere Netzgesellschaft eben aufbauen. Wo wir eben auch uns dann Gesetze angucken müssen, wie die gestaltet werden, ob das, was wir überhaupt haben, sinnvoll ist. Also ich halte ein Datenschutzgesetz nicht für sinnvoll, eine Kommunikationsgesellschaft zu gestalten, sondern da brauchen wir etwas anderes, etwas, was tatsächlich nachhaltig wirkt und nicht nur so ein Artikelgesetz ist, was überall seine Ausnahmen hat.
Und was könnte denn das sein?
Ich will die Antwort nicht geben. Ich könnte natürlich jetzt noch länger schwadronieren, aber das möchte ich nicht machen, sondern ich sage mal einfach, ein paar Milliarden in die Forschung stecken. Und das würde nicht so sein, wie ich es mir vorstelle. Ich kann sicherlich hier und da eine kleine Anregung geben, sondern es muss so sein, wie viele Leute es sich vorstellen, wie es sich entwickelt werden kann, wo einfach man sitzt und sich mal Gedanken darüber macht, wie das neue Grundrecht auf Integrität computertechnischer Systeme auszulegen ist, was das für uns bedeutet. Oder wie ich vielleicht tatsächlich urbane Netzstrukturen einbaue, so dass die Menschen zusammenkommen, die nur die Daten durch die Gegend fließen und Ähnliches. Ich muss mir überlegen, wie ich ein iPhone benutzen kann, ohne mir dauernd wie ein Idiot vorzukommen, weil ich überhaupt nicht weiß, was das Ding eigentlich über mich verrät und sendet und sonst wie. Wie muss um ein iPhone herum eine Gesetzgebung und Technik laufen, dass ich das eben mit gutem Gewissen benutzen kann, ohne dass der CIA oder irgendwelche Privatschirme da reingucken können.
Klingt für mich jetzt so ein bisschen wie so ein Digitalisierungskonvent, so wie man mal sich in der Verfassung gegeben hat, jetzt sozusagen die digitale Gesellschaft da neu zu verorten. Meinst du sowas?
Klingt jetzt erst mal nicht so schlecht, aber so ein bisschen, wie du das jetzt so sagst, klingt das so wie die Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung. Steckt 150.000 Euro in eine Veranstaltung, in der ein paar Leute zusammenkommen, die behaupten, sie hätten mal darüber nachgedacht und gehen dann wieder auseinander.
Das ist mir zu wenig.
Ich will Milliarden.
Du willst Milliarden, aber wo soll denn dann geforscht werden? Was finden wir denn noch heraus?
An den entsprechenden Fakultäten.
Ja, es muss an der Technik halt auch geforscht werden. Dann mit der Technik werden natürlich die Voraussetzungen geschaffen. Und je nachdem, wie du sie halt designst, dient sie bestimmten Interessen oder macht es besonders einfach. Und an der Stelle zum Beispiel kann man ansetzen. Bei den Gesetzen muss man natürlich auch was tun. Aber die Gesetze alleine richten das eben nicht. Bei Software zum Beispiel eine datenschutzfreundliche Standard-Einstellung verpflichten zu machen, fände ich wichtig. Weil im Moment ist es so, dass in der Regel Software alles Mögliche bei dir preisgibt, wenn du dich nicht richtig anstrengst. Und da über 90% der Leute die Standard-Einstellung ihrer Software nie ändern, ist das eben bei allen Leuten die Ahnungslos ist, dass die Software was über sie preisgibt. Und man könnte es bei vielen anderen Geräten eben auch anders einstellen. Das heißt dann aber auch, dass man über neue Geschäftsmodelle nachdenken muss. Denn einige Dinge finanzieren sich darüber, dass man die Leute dann eben besser erfassen kann, dass man damit Informationen hat, was man ihnen Verwerbung zukommen lassen kann usw. Da muss man drüber nachdenken. Und wie man Bezahlmodelle hinbekommt. Und wie Datenschutz in eine Technik integriert sein kann und nicht anschließend drauf gefropft. Also es muss von vornherein ein Bestandteil sein vom Nachdenken bei der Entwicklung. Und nicht nur etwas, was anschließend durch Gesetze aufgezwungen wird.
Und bei den Bezahlmodellen, um es gleich auch ganz klar zu sagen, es geht nicht darum, jetzt noch eine andere Form der Überweisung zu finden. Nein, ich möchte ein Bargeld haben. Ich möchte für ein Euro deine Podcast-Sendung runterladen können. Die sind ein Euro dir geben, ohne dass du weißt, dass er von mir kommt. Ohne dass du weißt, dass ich das gelesen habe. Ohne dass das bei mir irgendwo auftaucht. Ich möchte dir Bargeld geben. Also sowas wie das Open-Coin-Projekt, in dem wir auch schon mal versucht haben, dieses schaumische Idee des Bargeldes wieder als Open-Source zu beleben. In solche Dinge wirklich hineindenken, wobei es jetzt nicht nur darum geht, ein paar Coins zu entwickeln, sondern auch dann zu überlegen, wie verhindern wir Währungsspekulation, was damit so möglich wäre, dass man jede Währung einfach gegen die Wand fährt. Da muss richtig investiert werden. Ich möchte eine Möglichkeit haben, mit den Netzen wirtschaften zu können, ohne dass ich dauernd irgendwie an PayPal abdrücke oder solche Daten kraken. Und da müssen wir richtig rein. Und da verlange ich, sage ich mal, Leute, die die Möglichkeit haben, Gelder freizusetzen. Also ein Thomas de Maizière, der eben dann sagt, ich bin jetzt hier, ach nee, der ist Innenminister. Wer ist Finanzminister? Gut, von dem kriegen wir das Geld nicht. Aber der Mensch mit dem Inneren Frieden, der war schön. Aber wir brauchen diese Gelder, die müssen kommen, man muss forschen. Vielleicht würde es auch funktionieren, wenn ein paar Firmen Geld zusammenlegen. Ich glaube es nicht. Ich habe es probiert, in dem Moment, wo Firmen Geld zusammenlegen sollen, auch wenn sie selber davon was haben, aber andere profitieren auch davon, dann funktioniert das nicht. Ich habe das mit PGP probiert. Ich habe probiert, PGP, also Geld aufzutreiben, weil bei mir immer Firmen anriefen und wollten halt eine funktionierende Anwendung, die es leider bis heute nicht wirklich gibt. Das genug PGP-Projekt zählt für mich nicht. Das funktioniert immer noch nicht, sondern ein wirkliches Projekt. Aber es war nicht möglich, Firmen zu finden, die dafür sagen, ja, wir geben Teil rein und wir warten so lange, bis die anderen Firmen das dann auch haben und dann läuft das. Dafür, glaube ich, gibt es so etwas wie einen Staat, dass man dann zusammenlegt und tatsächlich eine Förderung von etwas macht, was tatsächlich allen zur Verfügung steht und nicht einzelne Firmen irgendwie Geld in den Rahmen schieben, nur damit die nicht arbeiten müssen, aller Siemens oder Deutsche Bahn oder weiß der Teufel. Und das wäre mir sehr wichtig. Und wenn wir das noch erleben dürfen, dass das anfängt, dann habe ich nicht umsonst gelebt.
Wir sind ja noch jung.
Ich muss auch wieder irgendwann zurück zum Sinus.
Ja, Sinus und Tangens, vielen Dank für die Ausführung zu des Beste aus den 80ern, 90ern und von heute. Ja, das ist schon erstaunlich. Mein Blick da jetzt schon irgendwie auf eine Menge Zeit zurück. Da kann man sich auch mal um 20 Jahre vertun ganz schnell. Mal gucken, was wir in 20 Jahren alles zu berichten wissen über diese Zeit.
In 20 Jahren werden wir auch noch ganz ordentlich was zu erzählen haben.
Kein Zweifel. Und ja, dann hoffen wir mal auch. Diese Erinnerung wird ja noch in 500 Jahren gehört werden. Dann können wir das dann auch vergleichen.
Vielen Dank, lieber Tim. Ich fand, das hast du ganz ordentlich gemacht.
Das hast du schön gesagt. Ja, und ich sag auch Tschüss und das war's. Bis bald bei Kraus Radio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!